it's
friday
may 20th
[Applause]
yeah
more maybe can you do a little more
enthusiasm dan
that's what i'm talking about
you guys see how hyped we are this
friday may 20th it's after dark
mate
you know it no it's not wednesday
why does he always say that it's
definitely friday oh that's why i was so
hyped
hey fred hey uh
hey fresh what's today
good one man and okay got another one
man what do you what the difference
between them
i can never understand what that guy's
saying fresh i asked what day is it
oh prettied up and then loaded coleman's
hair on off to the side man i'm gonna
look like that like get my good side
like that
yeah that's what he's
fresh what day is it it is wednesday
it's not wednesday dude it's friday
with a boom man the old cow flies
all right well today's episode is
sponsored by uh hellofresh thank you
and at the top of the show i want to
give a quick shout out to
my beautiful wives
a wonderful company
teddyfresh.com
hit me with that fashion music look at
ab he's rocking that rick and morty
long-sleeve tee
officially licensed
in collaboration hey hey hey work it
work it sam
is enjoying the what is that one called
yo
mock neck
something color block schmutz
sam is looking good lena
is looking
amazing in her what is that one called
eel
it's called something something
fresh i particularly i think this shirt
is
beautiful uh it looks amazing how does
it feel lina it's a good one right yeah
she's she says great she says it's great
it's great i love it
you hear that yeah
there it is and of course i'm wearing
this i don't even know if this is a
stock still kind of old one
do you want to plug anything ela
i'm wearing
unreleased simple unreleased and then my
old shredder and alfredo shirt okay
represent is anyone else rocking teddy
fresh this uh beautiful day
uh i've got one that's a little older
let's see it oh yeah that's a beautiful
piece i think that one's still on
on the website the floral teddy fresh
design
we love it we love to see it
guys if you're in the market for some
clothing
go on over to teddyfresh.com
there's this and way more cool stuff
so thank you thank you we actually we
have a really amazing show planned today
we're having a call in
i'm actually really excited about this
um
a gentleman
by the name of
uh jackson palmer
now this guy is the creator of dogecoin
so this guy's kind of a big deal
but what's interesting about jackson
palmer
is that he now
hates cryptocurrency
he thinks he he loathes it
uh and he's super smart
super insightful
and i think it's gonna be real
interesting to hear from from jackson a
little bit later on round two
um exciting
uh lots to talk about as well
um
including oh members up for members
thank you all the wonderful members
there's a new bts after the show that's
how it works right uh usually this one
is going to be tomorrow sorry guys but
it's a lot of footage it's from the
whole car oh okay
okay so tomorrow
um
let's see what top of the show we got
for you guys
we have the uh h3 couples face merge wow
i haven't seen this
oh the couple's face merged so this
sounds no i hate those wait no look at
it eila yo it looks like miz kiff
it kind of doesn't look like ms kip love
back me up i know you yeah i i think
like three of these kind of looks like
mischief yeah they all end up looking
like him yeah it's because it's the
eyebrows he has beautiful eyebrows
and the eyes too yeah yeah and beautiful
eyes apparently so there you go
um i had some uh kind of a strange thing
but
hey
let's see who's next
this is dan oh my goodness now this
i don't know what happened here but you
guys turn into like a seven-year-old
woman yeah this is allison
and dan
wow
just take that in huh
golly
that is awesome you guys look like and i
and i'm just saying this with peace and
love you guys look like uh
i'm not even gonna say it
let's just move on
today's one of the days where i'm gonna
just do the right thing oh thank you i
love those days yeah yeah
let's just move right past that
um
this beautiful son of a guy
sam and ian definitely love the best
whoa
you look like a kind of star dude like a
genderless
beauty yeah i like legs and uh ass so
wait
you kind of look like yourself in with
just nicer skin and beautiful eyes
yeah um he looks yassified yeah
yassified for sure i was samified
samified even better
what a beautiful comp what a beautiful
features
wow thank you thank you love this
love that um next up we have
dantel and zach that's a real person
dude that's just a real person what the
heck
it's gift
i feel like that's somebody i would
probably know he's like
[Laughter]
damn
okay shout out you guys are uh this one
did not turn out good i'm just going to
say that
oh
what
what the
what happened here
i
i don't know lena has a very small nose
that looks beautiful on her but not so
much on me
is that what it is the nose came up and
just it just doesn't fit either that's
all i could focus on i don't know
what happened you're not the heartthrob
anymore dude
well there you have it i would say
uh is there more yeah there's more my
favorite one's next yeah whoa is that
cam and love yeah
yeah
that's interesting that is interesting
that is also somebody i probably know
from israel
wow
do you see how there's two different
eyes i think it took one on my eyes and
one of what an interesting fellow you
guys created yeah
there you have it
so oh there's more wait who's this
that's olivia and pete davidson
oh god
something went wrong here
olivia the mouth pete's mouth
something's terribly wrong
uh olivia's back next week by the way
shout out to uh zunzans on the subreddit
for that one
that was fun
um
yo we have a new horrible pitch
oh let's watch um you guys we we talked
to br you want me to wait
there's been
something weird with the audio
did you guys fix it
there's something up with the audio oh
is that what is it all good there we are
hey gabe what's going on buddy you
taking a walk happy friday
it's thursday
thursday
no it's friday night
oh you got me really
good dude what i was like what i was
looking at my phone i was like hold on
you got me dude you taking a jog
you're just running dude
baby oh
mucho
[Applause]
little overcast huh it's cloudy oh
cloudy yeah what they call it may gray
oh do they call it
gray
do you like the overcast weather or you
prefer just sunny well
i i say stunning
like you're in a natural air conditioner
that's good right
i don't think about humidity or
[Music]
stickiness friday baby
what you doing this weekend
well
we'll probably have dinner with a couple
of friends and have a smoke
oh what are you smoking barbecue
you doing 420 acid
wait wait back it up
wait wait
so you're doing 420 and you said you're
dropping acid
no acid you know the cigar bread acid oh
this weekend it may not be the same game
next week
have you ever dropped acid gabe
no i haven't no okay
acid's a brand name on the cigar i see
that
it's a little confusing it's like
they're like flavored uh cigars yeah
like flavored white like acid flavor no
no no like they have like uh like a
christmas flavored one or like uh
gabe would you ever try acid have you
ever been curious to try it no no
yeah
dinner barbecue there may be no more
friday concept when you try it yeah you
when you try acid you learned that the
days of the week are arbitrary
we don't like that
yeah that's true that'd be nice yeah
yeah
we don't want that for good
[Music]
friday all right gabe you have a good
weekend okay buddy yeah have a good one
all right love you you take care you
have fun all right love you yeah next
weekend
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] baby all right love you
love ya all right love you buddy
i love you i love you
[Music]
[Laughter]
friday all right
take care buddy
take care
love
[Laughter]
that ya nice
always a pleasure always a pleasure to
hear from you
um on cameo you guys if you want uh a
shout out of course you can find him
there
speaking of cameos
um
you know we've been talking about abey's
boxing match quite a bit
hundar his opponent
uh bought
let's see
so honda here i'll just read his text he
said i totally forgot but i bought this
cameo because i thought it'd be funny
with the memes
this is the guy who says if he if he
dies he dies from rocky yeah the russian
he dies he dies
if he does
he does but i think he got confused and
he thought i was supposed to be
encouraging a.b
he said my coach would have killed me if
i sent this before the fight so here is
he dies he dies guy sending actually
words of encouragement to a b a little
bit of a backfire legendary
a message for a b
from myself from
brett
so look man you're fighting this guy in
a boxing what a voice charity events and
uh he says he's kind of like trump
they say trump yeah he's got this like
they say you're fighting this guy uh i'm
not i don't know i i i don't know much
about him he sounds like a real shallow
guy i don't know he sounds like a
character from batman yeah he basically
is he's a swedish legend oh really
yeah
dark flynn gang
dolph
dark
dolph yeah darth vader darth flutton
the greatest sith of all yeah
to scrawny too weak
he says if you die you die but i tell
you
kick his ass or
i must break you all right ab
all right have a great fight
good luck
and you will win
don't worry
you will break in
what
legendary wait so i don't understand why
didn't he send it because he's
encouraging a b yeah
because he killed one of the main
characters in rocky
yeah so he didn't want to send it
beforehand dude kenya is so awesome like
you can turn like a meme into a whole
career like he's famous for just being
like
if he does he does and now he's on
camera doing that all day yeah right
it's it's kind of like um
correcting society because all these
people they deserve it deserve it right
that's a good point either you know why
you should be able to cash in on that
yeah
if he dies he dies i wonder if he would
just do that for like a minute straight
if he dies he dies
i actually ordered a cameo from him for
my dad years ago
he said everything i asked for like word
for word so legend how much was it
i think it was 300 oh my goodness
you paid that
cameo split it 100 each
so i love for terrible first pitches and
apparently there's a new one this is
funny because we were just talking about
this guy i know and how he's everywhere
and i was like who is this guy and he
now here he's back
steve
uh
aoki steve ayotte zach i was hoping to i
forget what i was gonna do
anyway
um
let's see man there's a lot of bad first
pitches so let's see how bad is this one
a wine dab oh my god
whoa
wait what
oh what's happening something with the
audio has been happening is my audio
crazy right now audio's fixed now uh oh
no something else oh [ __ ]
oh the video okay okay
the video
you good
okay so yeah here it is dude what the
heck was that man i just say like if you
don't know how to throw a ball don't get
out there dude or do a little practice
you know i talked a lot i've talked
about it he's a dj apparently exactly
now i've talked [ __ ] about these first
pictures before and you all made me show
you that i have credentials you remember
that yes uh don't question me just the
other day we talked about the fact that
we were genuinely impressed by your uh
by your arm thank you guys very much i
threw us i threw up
right down the center i remember
oh you do
so don't question my my authority on
this i don't think anybody did
well i'm sure they're there but i'm just
saying like but what's the problem i
don't understand isn't it just for the
gay guy gaff and goof
and shits and giggles no yeah but you
don't want to be like dude when you
throw a bad first pitch you live forever
in infamy you get goofed on forever this
is baseball this ceremony but do you
really
dude
yes gary's first pitch from the howard i
haven't heard about that people on espn
have been making fun of him for decades
yeah they were talking about this one on
howard but there was a list and gary's
is still number one gary's is number one
yeah and i'm just saying you don't want
to be on that list for this dj is
anybody going to talk about that oh yeah
really
yes
i mean that was that wasn't as bad as
gary's it was wild what did he do was he
just threw it as hard as he could like
up yeah the throw doesn't make any sense
he threw it into the stand right that
was a weird one dude
but okay shout out you know
again let's just look at baba bowie's uh
pitch just to see show you guys
but it's embarrassing dude there's like
tens of thousand people watching you you
better just you know you've got to be
weirdo bro you just got to get out and
the thing is if you throw a perfect
pitch
dude you get street cred forever and
that's that's all i'm saying
like just practice a few times
right
how hard is that
just saying i sent you a multi-cam angle
oh yeah i need any more angles of this
thank you
yeah i need a multi cam this
oh this is baba booies yeah so so this
is garrett this is what's held to be the
worst ceremonial pitch of all time this
is the producer from the howard stern
show who's a huge uh baseball fan
and he even got a coach and practiced he
said he practiced look at that dude wait
i missed it and he's like a huge he's a
huge baseball fan so this was like he
was having nightmares about this i'm a
big meth fan buff
watch how embarrassed he is
after he throws it
he look at him he just puts his head in
shame he's like
i'm just gonna be made fun of forever
[Laughter]
honestly seeing it now it's not that bad
it's not that bad i think steve aoki was
worse i think steve's was worse yeah
yeah
wait there was one we saw that was like
way worse who was a celebrity dee was it
dj khaled or some hip hop 50 cent 50
cents
50 cents
yeah
i love these yeah that's more on par
with steve aoki's 50 cent's pitch was
nuts dude
um didn't fouchy throw a wild one too
was that recently
did he throw a wild one
um
he did what the heck
okay here we go
and you gotta love how he winds up too
like he he's he's like all right we're
gonna put the ball back here i'm gonna
throw a nice speeder down the
straight
boom dude oh my god i'm just saying dude
that's embarrassing just saying just
saying
you know they're laughing through the
pain let's be honest
but okay maybe i'm wrong maybe it's just
an honor either way
that's what i'm thinking you guys think
it's an honor either way or is this just
a fouchy okay now you know what i wonder
i wonder if your dad kind of like
interfered with your point of view about
this to take it too seriously you know
your dad with the [ __ ] balls am i am i
off base here this this is you don't
want to go through a horrible picture
right i'm i don't watch baseball so i'm
kind of with ila like if i if like
personally if i [ __ ] up i'd be like oh
whatever
yeah you don't want to be in that hall
of fame you do not want to be in there
thank you i mean there's not an
expectation for it to be like a fastball
down the center or anything right at all
just just a gentle lob you know yeah no
you just want to get it
within catching
yeah but i mean steve's uh
i'm kind of inclined to say that's the
worst one cause we i remember we look
like the worst one we reviewed these a
couple months ago yeah and the and the
audience had suggested uh you know some
people that have done well and done poor
and i don't remember any being like that
was almost threw it into the balcony
yeah that was nuts well here's fauci by
the way
and dude i'm sorry but i've heard lots
of conspiracies about this guy but
it's all true
this guy's the first american
fauci is a he's a threat to our
to our democracy yep
maybe i'm off base but i just think that
i don't think you're offering that you
can never recover from that i think it's
just you either uh
know it or don't kind of like
good you got to move to canada after
that i think it's
a pr nightmare
canadian teams and mlb i see a few
people saying they're they're with you
on this thank you
you see it's not just me it's not just
me yeah i was just wondering did gary
like brand new brainwashing i get it
that's that's a fair thing to wonder it
could be but a baseball is the american
pastime you got to throw a ball sure you
got to learn how to throw a ball you
think we could orchestrate getting your
dad
a first pitch an honorary first pitch
that would be him for that
he would go he would lose his mind dude
that would be
the aim if we could do that he'd
probably throw a terrible one too i know
it would be such good content for this
house
wait how could well so i don't know
because oh jenna marbles got one see
good i remember yeah yeah we watched it
and sure
oh yeah see that's so cool right yeah
that's so cool
he's so cute i think maybe she played
softball or something i could be wrong
but look at that that's a clean one dude
that's a clean pitch
makes it look
easy yeah she did make it look easy that
was impressive didn't carly rae jepsen
have a bad one too
i'm like vaguely remembering carly lee
who now carly rae jepsen she sang that
song call me maybe
we could try maybe we could try you know
what would be the best dan is if uh i
went out there with my dad because i
don't think they're gonna let my dad
throw like a dodger stadium like who
where can we find some weird off-brand
oakland a's like
[Music]
like no my dad's a die-hard dodger fan
but they're not going to let my dad who
is that they're just that it's like
they're not going to let us do it games
they play here
we can reach out and see they might let
me
maybe in which i'd have to bring my dad
out there and then do like a switcheroo
he'd be proud
we can reach out and see let's see let's
see
maybe we could just make up a story
about how we just turn it into like a
make-a-wish thing
[Laughter]
like that's kind of the only way we're
gonna make this oh my god you
know oh jesus
hey
uh and in the role of a lifetime and the
role of a lifetime wait so i gotta try
since i'm american now
i never tried you never throwing a ball
no should we set it up you want to do it
now no no
no no that's very american if not now
when if not now when if not you then who
in a few weeks
okay
we'll hold you to that next few weeks
hold on
because you don't want to throw a bad
pitch it would be embarrassing right
weren't you just saying
wait that's true i literally never even
held a ball i'm gonna throw that in my
hands
set it up
oh my god all right ela is about to go
uh
she's about to throw the honorary
whatever
of the friday episode
so here almost whatever
so
so it's going to be oh is that a real
how did you get a ball so fast what is
wrong with you guys
wow oh this wait this isn't an official
ball
this is soft and rubbery and light so
that'll be easier for you
okay
now now basically i mean i
just i don't know what i don't know what
to do
look at your target
follow through throw it harder than you
think you would have to
i would say that's that's not good
advice not as hard as steve
awakey
awakey
aoki bakey awakey
steven stephen are you a waiki
okay
so dan you were so quick to set this up
i remember you didn't want to throw on
camera
mr dan uh-huh that's true you know why
because it would be embarrassing to [ __ ]
up in front of a bunch of people
just
you set this up quicker than i've ever
seen you set anything up
[Music]
okay so uh we have to get the camera set
up
but uh are the cameras set up we need to
get a mic set up um
but basically
uh i'm going to announce this aby is
going to catch it
and uh i will let it know and ela's
going to throw a steamer right down the
lane
so bear with us just one sec we're
getting set up here
[Music]
yeah great technique
[Music]
that form
all right
[Music]
so ela is warming up she's doing some uh
stretching right now
the dogs are here in full support
[Music]
ethan's uh stance
he's looking like the
you know da vinci's a vitruvian man
[Music]
peak performance
uh we'll here go ahead talk go ahead hey
okay we're on so guys welcome to the
first inaugural
h3
uh baseball game
friday may 20th we're about to get this
underway now ela is here to throw our
first ceremonial pitch
a b
is going to be receiving it go ahead
right down there if you can crouch yeah
right in front of the boxes
okay are you ready
now the goal i don't know if you know
but the goal is basically to get it
there's a strike zone honestly if you
get it anywhere within hand range of
baby i'll be impressed okay you're gonna
pass the test
all right ela whenever you're ready
anywhere there no bouncing before either
it's got to be a straight
you can't no bounce you can't bounce it
and then it goes to me yeah
all right ready
here we go
i can tell there's going to be a
disaster just based on that hand motion
oh no it's not it's gonna it's more
likely to hit me i think
yeah i mean yes
essentially yes
i don't i don't i think what you're
doing
you're like twisting your body that's
not good
it's all it's going to be all in your
arm it's going to be all in your arm
yeah
you don't want to throw it with your
waist
do whatever is comfortable you know
i'm not going to t you're not going to
learn how to throw a pitch in one one
thing just you know follow your heart
that looks yeah
no he's being fine
[Music]
ela threw up basically
a perfect pitch
holy [ __ ]
dude
that was a perfect line drive
straight to a b and they kill and that
and ela's putting on her cowboy hatch is
ready to do a victory lap now dan are
you ready to throw your pitch
oh i have to now all right then
dan's been talking a lot of smashing
serious [ __ ]
he's been talking i was saying i didn't
want to do this for the exact reason
that you were explaining that you don't
want any inspiration
so dan is already talking up that this
is going to be
okay that's that's yeah that's good
yeah
i think traditionally it's
come okay you know what not that bad i
think traditionally it's going to be way
further
this is like easy okay don't take it
away
yeah
yeah like that i think that well that's
probably yeah all right let's see here
we go
dan said he's just gonna throw it at me
here he goes lining up
[Music]
that's it that's a good pitch that's a
good pitch dan passes van passes what
can i say we got a whole we all got a
whole office of true blue
blooded americans anyone else want to
step to the plate while we're here
zach go ahead zach zach full of
confidence
zach is throwing his hair back full of
confidence
let's see what he's got i already forgot
why we're even doing this go back back
back
that's good that's good that's good
that's good zach's taking it back quite
a bit
confident
confident sometimes hubris sometimes uh
sinks the ship he's doing stretches go
ahead zach whenever you're ready
zach is about to throw
i would say of the three probably the
worst but not a tragedy
zach wants to redo it
i don't think he wait he's going he's
going all the way to the wall
i don't know why okay zach is trying to
improve a point
okay zach so zack's winding up
i mean
it's fun you're fine
you're fine zach you're fine
he just
zach is blaming abe oh my god
oh my god zach is blaming ab but i gotta
say as the observer of that throw it did
fall short but it was a it was on it was
like you know the line was right
okay exciting stuff here i'll leave this
mic here i'll just put it right here dan
yeah you can
alright we're good
sad gush darn it
i gotta say though very impressive feat
by um ela absolutely dan showed his
um
his grit as well and zach i'm not gonna
hate on you it wasn't that bad it's not
a hall of famer bad or anything like
that it didn't go like to the complete
opposite direction yeah it did not no
that's what i mean the line was there i
want to see a b throw [ __ ]
maybe just did a boxing match
did you
yeah
i didn't throw it but he knocked honda
athletically i proved myself yeah
exactly all right i'll give you that
i like to see av throw pitch too
all right let's go oh you know what it's
fine we're sitting down next time next
time but um
damn ela that was really good for
someone that never threw a ball i am
super thankful thank you i really
thought i was going to do it gary
delabicio
you know we need a compilation of gilas
first pitch that was sick
so there you have it guys
impressive you though very thank you
thank you very much i take my
american-ness very seriously yeah
yeah baby
[Music]
um
by the way we have a new one from our
boy
our boy in blue of course i'm talking
about
america's favorite
defense attorney
[Music]
let's see what he's up to today with my
great client here we just crushed this
let me just read this seven years prison
offered for two felonies
wait
that sounds pretty serious that's pretty
serious it got it got reduced to one
misdemeanor and zero prison let's go
let's go this man let's go this man is
accused of murdering his wife and child
the evidence was pretty overwhelming but
uh one of the cops was drunk at the time
and we were able to get the whole thing
thrown out
this case
he was facing a felony case with two
strikes a domestic violence case
the uh complaining witness in the case
also requested a restraining order
against him so we used that court case
in another court as an opportunity to
cross-examine her under oath on the
stand like a deposition
uh totally obliter obliterated her
credibility at that hearing and showed
that she was perjuring herself
now in the end we resolved this case for
a misdemeanor two strike felonies were
reduced to one misdemeanor
he was facing seven years prison how
much prison are you facing now none
zero zero how are you feeling i'm
feeling great i'm free
let's go
what about the i i was like dude
someone's trying to get a restraining
order he's like she's unable to get the
restraining order we have totally
eviscerated her credibility let's go
and this and we're like where are you
headed now that you're free straight to
her house
[Laughter]
let's go but you know what the man is
good at his job you can never say he's
not good at his job
no clearly and our roads are full of
drunk drivers
because of his fine work and he is very
good yeah
let's go
i love that man yeah
come on
um
you guys know i live in an echo chamber
right
it's pretty pathetic
some say the biggest echo chamber
you would say that
a good good good good good time
great time some say the best one wow
intrigue
some say the most intriguing
i did a whole apology sam are you
recovering the best apology
it does kind of slap though yeah some
say it slaps the most
it's such a roller coaster isn't it
i just
uh it's the most intense roller coaster
it
is it really is
you're brendan you became brendan
i embodied him and i'm joe rogan yep
i like i said uh the rolieus roller
coaster yeah suggested that as an
alternative in the comments it's
definitely
it's kind of fun to have someone back
you up like that and echo you oh it's
the most fun
i feel good i feel so good it's the best
you've ever felt it's like yeah that
[ __ ] was true what i just said it's the
truest thing you've ever like an
exclamation mark yeah the loudest thing
you've ever said thank you bro yeah
so
um by the way speaking of roles i am no
longer driving a rolls royce
i am so happy
we thought we were stuck with it for
five years
oh my god i'm so happy they were so i
was like man i did not like that car
it did like 12 miles to the gallon oh my
god and like we had two baby seats in
the back you don't you don't think
you're supposed to put baby seats in a
rolls-royce it's like because the door
opens the opposite way
the babysit faces like away from the
windshield
it's like you can't even reach the baby
you can't you try to put him in the car
seat and you can't even physically do it
well and then the weirdest part is that
it's such a massive car but when eel
would sit in the middle
of the kids she would have no space yeah
i barely fit
so
i wasn't sure they were going to take it
back because i was locked in like this
insanely long
lease but they were so desperate for
cars because there's a car shortage
uh they took it back canceled the lease
they even paid me it was kind of insane
yeah
so
i'm no longer driving that thing man i'm
just couldn't be happier such a
ridiculous car it's not even nice it's
beautiful it's just a total stand status
symbol because that's what it is it's
really not that nice inside i have to
say it's super antiquated
it's not tech like
up to date
that's a big deal like the navigation
the whole inside interior
is just
group it's just bad man it's just bad
and i gotta say you know for how much
that car cost the ac wasn't that [ __ ]
good either oh that's unexpected i
wanted some jet engines and they also
wasn't doing it it's just kind of like
the attention that you get in it is just
not cool like at least not for us it's
not our vibe like every time you stop at
a red light somebody's gotta be like yo
look at that what do you do that was the
worst part that was the biggest reason
uh because that was my daily commuter
and it's just like
i'm just some [ __ ] in this one person
in this massive colony that gets 12
miles to the gallon
and
and then everyone's looking at you it's
such a flashy car and i don't know just
you want to come to my car and suck my
car
[Music]
but in a rolls-royce that would be more
compelling i think
i'm just saying oh man
that was about the brendan shaw i didn't
i didn't proposition anyone yeah that
took me a minute to please can we tell
them uh
what you got now
sure
so
it's funny it was totally unintentional
but ethan went from matching his
previous co-host to matching his grand
co-host dude it was not what i meant to
do at all i didn't even realize yeah so
i got porsha makes this all-electric car
it's got four seats
and i was it's by the way half the price
literally half the price of the rolls
royce even in this insane market i went
to buy a car
they tell me the ticket price and they
go and then on top of that of course is
20 000 because you know [ __ ] you just
because they're up charging everything
20 000 on top jesus
i was like okay whatever but even with
that massive up charge it's still half
the price
of the rolls royce which is awesome but
yeah i have the same exact car as this
on which was not by design
i don't want anyone to say that is it
the same color no it's a different color
different interior i got baby blue i
think it's blue or something i think
yours is nicer than her song oh yeah of
course you'd say well no i like that
personally i wish you had someone like
that you've had one all along
what happened before anyone saw says
that i'm comping hassan everyone i went
there
right now
i agree it's on sam i went there to test
drive a different car and i said hey do
you guys have a all electric cars
because i didn't know and she's like
yeah we got one it just arrived today
the person canceled their order
and like i got insanely lucky that it
was there i didn't specify it i didn't
know it was there i don't want to hear
any [ __ ]
about uh habena hassan sip and yes the
ac is [ __ ] insane dude
it blasts my head back i turn that [ __ ]
on
which is what i want that's what i
expect from a rolls-royce man that car
sucks did you say that it's like a light
blue
mine yeah no it's chalk it's gray oh
gray yeah hassan's is the label right
yeah that's right
now i'm very happy with it though
also has
fake engine noise which is pretty
interesting yeah
i turn it off i like the quiet
but i guess the thing is with porsches
they're super loud
we had one before that was i love you i
always drove with the loud
loud option on
you did i didn't like the noise i love
it
well i guess some porsche drivers like
the noise so they put in this option to
make it sound like a real car which is
kind of silly but no but the previous
one was real
yeah the previous one was yeah a real
engine
but i'm saying i'll on the way home i'll
play you the fake okay it sounds it
plays it in the car and outside the car
so that people can hear you coming
that seems like the more important part
is the right car yeah yeah it is i guess
but uh i'm not hey listen watch where
you're walking i don't know what to tell
you
i'm coming in
i'm driving here i'm like a dog
i wouldn't know what to do if i got it
yeah so i have the same
car as hassan and i'm sure
that whatever show i do next i'll end up
with the same cars
yeah but if you ever if you ever
if you have a lot of money to waste
don't buy a [ __ ] rolls royce please
not impressed
um
we should do our ad read for the day
it's that time oh hassan is watching uh
hassan
uh apparently hassan if you are watching
zach says my car is cooler than me way
better
wait is is it actually different somehow
well the color of the car was just like
the interior is different oh okay yeah
but otherwise the car itself is
identical hassan's beautiful don't get
me wrong but i i personally i like the
color combo you guys zach was about to
put his dick in the exhaust pipe
that thing is done because i'm a i'm a
huge porsche
favorite car zach almost [ __ ] on my
hood
it's beautiful no i i love hassan's
color to be honest to even it out oh
here we go
[Music]
the blue is so nice i didn't see yours
yet though so oh you didn't even see it
i mean
that blue i think is like the most
beautiful blue i've seen on a car gray
chalk girl i'm still i'm talking yeah
bro thick it's though
gray is very annoying
i'm just saying ela i mean you don't
like white cars you saw that
neutrals are very in right now they're
very and that include brown and grays
right anyway here is uh
here is me at the porsche dealership i
don't
who am i which one am i you are
definitely michael and hassan
this is brian why i'm always michael
scott in these comparisons guys
can i not beat michael scott once
uh
it's so true though isn't it
um okay let's move on hassan are you
still watching um yes he is hi brother
so good episode this friday right or i
mean this yesterday we had a good app
yesterday people really liked it yeah i
haven't watched it yet
yep all right well hassan i hate to do
this to you well if you're watching i'm
not gonna do an ad read let's entertain
the people
uh let's see
um
oh you're gonna like this hassan jordan
peterson i don't know if you saw this
but this is [ __ ] amazing jordan
peterson's audiobook is off the rails
bro
it's off the freaking rails we should
probably give like a little bit of a
content warning here like this is yeah
pretty [ __ ] wild grandma's just a
warning in general i don't even know
what kind of learning you're giving i'm
assuming he's talking about a dream and
not something that actually happened i
hope so but he's talking about oh is it
yes well he's like my grandma brushed
her
that would actually explain a lot about
him but i think it was real
but zach i told zach um did you buy the
audiobook because we need to comb
through that whole day we're we're gonna
work on it i'm gonna i'll probably work
on that over the weekend this is
important this this is big
so but this is like sound bite heaven i
mean i'm just gonna let this run here
listen
this is not by the way i have to say
this is not like an ai this is really
jordan peterson saying this real quick
has sound left oh
well let's do it anyway
um
this is not
a deep fake this is truly his words from
his book i saw my maternal grandmother
sitting by the bank of a swimming pool
which was also a river
her genital region was exposed dimly it
had the appearance of a thick mat of
hair
she was stroking herself absent-mindedly
she walked over to me with a handful of
pubic hair compacted into something
resembling a large artist's paintbrush
she pushed this at my face
i raised my arm several times to deflect
her hand
finally unwilling to hurt her or
interfere with her any further i let her
have her way
she stroked my face with the brush
gently and said like a child isn't it
soft
that music is added by the way
i kind of wish it wasn't i know well
we'll get the audio book and we'll yeah
we'll clip the uh but i pulled like the
clean sound bite wait raise it up a
little bit raise it up
hello it's up
oh what happened the clip cuts off at
like the 30 seconds oh it's just dead
air yeah interesting interesting edit
gently and said like a child isn't it
soft i looked at her face and said yes
grandma
saw
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] wacky bro some [ __ ]
just keep to yourself
i mean genuinely like sometimes you have
dreams you don't need to tell everyone
about it her genital region was exposed
yeah yeah i mean jordan just just keep
that to yourself she was stroking
herself absent-mindedly no
don't share that with me it had the
appearance of a thick mat of hair
please keep that to yourself jordan it's
just so unnecessary i let her have her
way
wait what you let who wait i let her
have her way
no
that's your grandma man that ain't right
please for christ's sake
just take it easy please jordan oh
all right let's thank our sponsor
hellofresh uh thank you it's just one
sponsor today so stand by
hellofresh is the
number one
delivery meal kit in america why is that
because you can get stuff like this
bro what is in that
[Music]
it could be beans cheese rice guacamole
sour cream salsa
it could be
human flesh
it could be horse hair
it could be your grandmother it could be
toenail clippings
could be literally just dirt
um we don't know what's in that burrito
i actually
there's uh somebody on the subreddit did
uh oh and x-ray vision yeah oh so it is
thumbtack yeah
it was just it's actually just
thumbtacks yeah which isn't good burrito
filling if you ask me shout out okay
satron for uh that that's a bad service
they didn't just to be clear they didn't
send them that's that's fake news no my
burrito's delicious okay
there's some real food um dude hello
fresh is easy fun and affordable
super troopers love
hella fresh this is all pictures we get
from our fupa
troopers look at these beautifully fresh
healthy
delicious meals so easy to cook
and the thing that i love about
hellofresh is it's like balanced it's
healthy it's delicious and frankly it is
fun super easy to clean up super easy
to cook
they send you the perfect pre-portioned
ingredients
and instructions with information
interesting information cooking
techniques to tell you exactly what you
need to do to make a perfect home-cooked
meal it's actually 72 percent cheaper
than dining at a restaurant and it's
even cheaper than grocery shopping
because you know you don't have to buy a
bushel of uh
stuff that you're not the only need for
one meal you know what i mean
uh they've got new menus releasing all
the time they have mediterranean recipes
that are filled with fresh fruit and
veggies nuts olive oils and packed with
fiber
for
nourishing
balance
also
a hello
hello fresh has fit and dude that was cl
it almost said fresh and fit i was
wondering if you're about to say that
and it says it here hello fresh and fit
it says that and wholesome recipes for
satisfying the nutritious meals
you can feel good about
you know the six recipes per week to
choose from including a low calorie and
carb conscious option and you know
they also have tastiest stuff like look
at this they have tempora bowls garden
spinach ricotta ravioli one pot creamy
lemon dill chicken soup
damn
yeah i love it everyone who
gets it loves it um food troopers love
it go to hellofresh.com
afterdark16
and use the code after dark 16 for up to
16 free meals and three free gifts what
are we looking at here
that is someone at the boxing event
with abe's burrito
so many people had signs with burritos
on it
i signed an actual burrito
you did yeah and i felt bad because i
accidentally tore through the tin foil
and i signed it with permanent marker
yeah i'm just saying you can't buy
you can't buy clout like that hello
fresh and then when he was fighting
everyone was spamming burritos in chat
yep
i don't know if everybody paid attention
to our place there was one moment where
i seriously saw burritos everywhere
yeah in our chat in our place and on
reddit oh our place you were seeing
burritos everywhere yeah
like amy's burritos
yeah i saw you she
loved it i posted it on my store yeah
that baby's burrito literally was on our
place yeah every there were all kinds of
little burritos yeah what
was that a dream did your grandma come
and put her pubes in your face maybe
did that really happen i did have proof
i posted it on my stories i don't know
if it was my burrito but i did see the
burritos my grandma came with her pups
in her hand like an artist brush and she
had her way with me
uh go to
hellfresh.com15 and use code after arc
16 for up to 16 free meals and three
free gifts guys hello fresh is america's
number one meal kit and we love them
thank you to our sponsor and that's it
my grandma
sat in my face
her pubes covered me all the way down to
the back of my head
i was in a tent of my grandmother's
pubes
her vagina smelled like old
old rusty chicken she was stroking
herself absent-mindedly
my grandma's vagina smelled like bingo
and buffet
smelled like ginger the region was like
my family spelled like that
my grandma was like
my grandma
my grandma was running the early bird
special on her vagina and she let me
dive right in it had the appearance of a
thick mat of hair
this man is so [ __ ] great i let her
have her way i let grandma have her way
oh wait did i just see it what was that
oh somebody found the burritos from that
place all right pull it up but you gotta
pull it so all right so here's the
burritos those are rolls of bread those
are baguettes those are baguettes this
is this is fair enough this is fake
newsie and i don't know why you're
saying this it was my burrito wait why
was everyone holding a baguette though
that is interesting it was the french uh
delegation oh there oh that's what i
wanted
and everything did it be fair to you ela
it has the grill mark yeah really it
looks like the baby burrito yeah i feel
you breadcrumb you know what's funny my
burrito is actually a french baguette
uh no
it wasn't
why am i like my like voice is like
shaky
my grandma
her pubes were long like a
like a
like
what do you call the things you tie
between trees a cot or is it hammock oh
yeah my grandma my we made a hammock for
my grandmother's pubes
she was on laying on the grass
her pubes were 20 feet long i let her
have her way we made a wonderful hammer
from my grandma's pubes
and then i could smell the subtle waft
of her vagina the early bird special was
ready for genital region i was ready for
the buffet of grandma's vagina
and i had a full
course meal you know i was playing these
back
practicing my jordan peterson impression
and i was just i kept repeating it and
saying it after like i let her have her
way
i let her have her way her vagina
i let her have her way
the appearance of a thick mat of hair
[Laughter]
my grandma's hair
we used it like a paintbrush it dreamed
of her
butthole it was hard to tell where her
butthole and vagina began the pubes were
everywhere it was in her gooch i
couldn't see a damn thing
trying to get to her vagina was like
was like a
bucking through a thick
rain forest it gave me flashbacks to
vietnam
what did we do without pubes
where would we be without grandma's
pubes nowhere
i just got ela doing it
oh hello there jordan peterson hila how
are you doing today
what would you do without zach
where would we be without zach
her pubes were thick like a
like uh
like summer in mongolia
i don't know
you really need a sickle and a hammer to
get through that that's what the
communists do you know get through the
pubes
i needed a i needed a neo marxist to
sickle her pubes
i love that man
yeah wait till we get our hands on that
whole audiobook it's gonna be they're
gonna be hell to pay oh yeah
um god we should get to some
stories so we have a call in at two
which is about 15 minutes so perhaps we
should do something
relatively short
i mean philly d
yeah that i mean we could talk about the
deaf noodles thing you think i don't
maybe that will take too long there's
not a lot of information out there right
about stuff about it yeah why don't we
talk about that and then so deaf noodles
announced
that he is suing keemstar now this is
really
took me by surprise i have to say
murderer
um
and i can't say that keemstar doesn't
deserve it
but let's analyze this
from a you know completely fair i'm
going to be
impartial as possible obviously i like
def and hate keemstar as you guys know
and keemstar has defamed me and many
other people so but let's look at this
impartially um here first of all this is
where he announced it right half that
slugs anyway folks as you read in the
title of the video i am suing keemstar
now for those of you who started
following me recently and are not aware
nearly one year ago keemstar knowingly
published false and defamatory
allegations against me he claimed i
groomed numerous underage girls keemstar
has since confessed twice to fabricating
these allegations to punish me he has
never officially retracted these
allegations nor has he ever corrected
them these allegations have caused me
great harm socially and professionally i
am now suing him to clear my name of
these false allegations and to hold him
accountable for knowingly making false
accusations and our power cleanser
can i say i have a i can be a witness in
a way
go ahead some sort of a witness because
i remember when kim starr posted that
and then i think maybe one of you guys
shared it or something
and when i saw that
that tweet or headline whatever it was i
was like oh no not there like i had the
same reaction right because we were all
loving him and i was like you know it's
like when the me too happens and it's
like oh no not my favorite actor or
i was i had that feeling like not deaf
and then um
and then i was like oh obviously it's
keemstar so gotta look into it but
it did that moment to me and then it's
like at the back of your head you know
it's there there's like maybe
so i had the same exact reaction when i
saw that
i was like holy [ __ ] you know i believed
it when i saw it because i don't know
keemstar he
the thing about keemstar is
he professes to be a legitimate news
source obviously that's debatable for
people that know him well
i don't think the people that consume
his content necessarily
know what a liar he is
you know what i mean
but also
um
but also he's per he's reported on
several very serious allegations
of essay and stuff
so like taken if you take his track
record
as a news person who has broke several
serious stories of this nature
i think you have a really good argument
that he
uh
has you know
breached his responsibilities here
and now defamation well let me read so
this is the tweet he's referring to def
def noodles has allegedly groomed girls
ages 12 to 15. big youtuber source said
victims are scared of him and wish to
stay anonymous but may come forward soon
hashtag drumler and then he responded to
it saying death noodles has declined to
give us a comment on these allegations
made against him now what's interesting
is this tweet's still up
and he never retracted it
um
only a year later
uh
a year let's see a year later
he said this this is the tweet this is
in the filing right yep
so this is actually also in the filing
he says
um
don't you remember he kept posting
non-stop fake
p-word stories on youtube so i posted
this tweet to mock him in may 2021
everyone knows this is a joke that i'm
mocking him but now he's taking it
completely out of context acting like a
serious allegation so what's interesting
about this statement
is
one
so def i have to explain defamation
because a lot of people don't understand
it defamation isn't just lying about
someone it's when you lie about someone
maliciously with knowing to harm their
reputation while
knowing
that it's not true
that's a super high bar to reach and
what this tweet does
which was posted a year later
um
actually proves
malicious tent and he knew it wasn't
true
so it's kind of a weird tweet because on
one hand he's saying you know that it
was a joke
and everybody knew that it wasn't
serious
i actually don't believe that i think
the only i did the only reason people
knew it wasn't serious is because
deaf noodles kept talking about it and
being like this is [ __ ] he made it
up and stuff like that
but keemstar never uh clarified
uh or or retracted it so like
the original here
yeah the original the original's still
up i mean yeah
and keemstar has done that to me he made
a video saying i stole money from a
video game to
embezzled money and i pro i did a whole
video proving that it wasn't true and
it's still up so like technically i have
a i have i i could technically sue him
for defamation
um
the same way right
by the way if he's saying that everybody
knew it was a joke it's like let's look
at the comment do people know it's a
joke yeah he has some comments in the
filing right to show that people thought
it thought it was real exactly
um
did you guys anyone read the full filing
i haven't read i mean i just saw i just
saw excerpts and screenshots and stuff
i read through it i mean i'm no lawyer
but here it is it's not an expert
opinion but
yeah i mean like you said because you've
been dealing with the ryan kavanagh
[ __ ] lately defamation uh has been
i've been sued twice for defamation once
by matt haas once by rank right and so
um wait my house did definitely yeah
yeah
that got thrown out all right
and so yeah uh we've explored that quite
a bit and like you said it is a
at least in the united states uh the
laws are not state by state uh
california has a really strong anti-slap
thing for public figures and new york
actually has a new anti-slap law that is
kind of unexplored so
um
it's hard to
say which direction this is going
but here's the filing
here's the tweet we just read
um
and basically it's a really simple
filing it's quite actually
it's quite short only nine pages pretty
sure you have like 30 pages on these
things
um
it's 14 pages just nine actually dark
vibe
but um
so what's in so right off the bat you
know you have to say like
when you're suing someone for defamation
you just have to assume you're
automatically at the on the back foot so
like just off the bat because of the
nature of defamation lawsuits i'll say
that keemstar is likely to win
that being said
it's not a slam dunk for him i think
this is really interesting case
here
and i think keemstar's likely defense is
going to be
basically
they're going to say that
the tucker carlson defense yeah no
nobody rational would take me serious
nobody rational would take me serious
it's just entertainment wouldn't you
have to prove that like
he makes jokes like this all the time or
something you know like you have to show
that there is a reason to think that
this was a joke i'll tell you exactly
how it's going to play out so they filed
this now keemstar's lawyers have to
respond they're going to respond by
saying keemstar is an entertainer he's
not a news person nobody would take
these charges seriously
now if i was deaf's lawyer what i would
do in response to that find all the
times that he says that he's reporting
news find all the times he said i just
report the news find all the times he's
talked about serious times he's reported
on essay allegations and show
meticulously that he is serious news
person and not only that he has a
propensity to report on
essay in a serious manner
and then you know keemstar and
uh add to all that
the old guy that was fakely accused of
that's just a wrong he's done it before
yeah a fantastic example
and and that had uh
you know dire
dire consequences
um
and then and then i think keemstar's
lawyers are just going to have to try to
dispel
one by one each example that deaf
noodles lawyers can bring up but that's
the so that he files his
his initial one keemstars lawyers
respond and then he responds to that and
then keemstar response to that
and basically what's going to happen is
keemstar's lawyers are going to file the
anti-slap
which basically means that
because
because death noodles is a public figure
um
he basically it's really hard to defame
public figures and it it's basically
like i have free speech and i can say
whatever the [ __ ] i want
and this person's just trying to silence
me that's what the anti-slap's for which
is actually really true in the case of
ryan cavanaugh and matt haas
and i don't know you know this is a
really interesting case i don't think
keemstar keemstar thinks this is an easy
dub it's not going to be i this could go
either way frankly i'm just saying it's
probably going to go to keemstar just
because of the nature of defamation
lawsuits
but
this is this isn't i think he has a
pretty good case though death
yeah he's got him admitting that he
said it maliciously
um which is like the hardest hurdle like
that's the one that's specifically the
part that most yeah how can you possibly
prove him john right how can you
possibly prove that the person knew it
was a lie and said it maliciously short
of them saying i made this lie up
maliciously which is what keemstar did
pretty incredible i have been caught in
4k but the problem is like even in what
you said ila
you said i saw the allegation yeah and i
saw it was from keemstar and i said oh i
better look into that that's keemstar's
defense that's literally yeah exactly
that's his defense is going to be that
he's a joke a walking joke yeah but like
i walked out exactly you said yeah
and this was from keemstar he's gonna
have to write that with his lawyer
though i'm a walking l therefore nobody
takes me seriously therefore this
couldn't have been it's true whatever
his lawyer has to write in there we're
gonna we have to quote that for a time
whenever he reports the news we'll be
like actually no you know he's gonna be
at the crossroad like are you really a
news person or are you a walking joke
yeah you gotta fix me
you know unfortunately
little dear kimmy
unfortunately if first of all i am
rooting for deaf noodles because
keemstar is a piece [ __ ] and death
noodles is a friend of mine and keemstar
is a vile human being he doesn't do this
to just death noodles he does it to
everyone
but
you know i think he should add the in
terms of i mean the fact that also he
still hasn't removed the tweet shows
like no remorse on his and no no attempt
of trying to make it right right that
does kind of factor into lawsuits
usually
i don't like personally i don't really
love the precedent
of youtubers suing each other for
defamation i don't know
but like i really think this is that
because who the [ __ ] else would get sued
for defamation other than keemstar
and def says that it had
a genuine financial impact on him he
lost sponsorship that's very interesting
that's very interesting that's part of
the
i don't know if that factors into the
defamation part or if it just factors
into yeah
yeah no it if you can prove damages it's
all the better right okay so
definitely i mean
yeah it's not great yeah but keemstar's
defamed lots of people basher
uh tobiscus um
you know there was even a dm leaked
where keemstar was saying
that to basher if you guys remember that
far back
that he was gonna get girls to lie and
make [ __ ] up about him if he didn't come
on a show or what was the context to my
knowledge though he denies that that was
real
um but yeah saying something like you
better stop talking about me or i'll
have two interviews set up with underage
girls too to lie about you yeah
yeah it was it wasn't real guys
according to keemstar
well there you go who is a beacon of
truth and
and the transparency dumb [ __ ] a
b
[Laughter]
so um
it's very it's very very interesting but
i have to say from just from my
perspective when i saw that i thought it
was true for a minute and i saw all his
goons were echoing it turned into like a
meme of theirs that they kept echoing it
but
it wasn't said like ironically they were
genuinely it seemed like they were
generally trying to
spread that rumor and i thought it was
true for a minute until i realized i
watched deaf noodles videos like oh
they're just literally making that up
like it's kind of [ __ ] nuts oh one
other
i think important aspect of it that we
we didn't mention when we were
describing it is the second
follow-up tweet is also included def
noodles has declined to give us a
comment on these allegations and made
against him def in the filing says that
a that's not true and b in fact keem
blocked him right before he posted this
so that def couldn't even interact with
it or defend himself that's pretty bad
too again because yeah and he sees this
he's like oh make an obvious joke but
it's not an obvious joke
actually at all
and especially since he never corrected
it till a year later
you know
but yeah people someone pointed out that
keemstar calls death noodles defamation
noodles and so if def actually wins a
defamation case i guess keemstar that's
going to be a dub
i saw somebody saying the chat death to
all kim stars
right
no it's a good one
so you know what i wish that
i wish in a way that
it didn't have to come to this obviously
i would i've never sued anyone in my
life if i was going to sue someone for
defamation would be keemstar
i'm personally not a litigious person i
don't want to sue anyone for anything
um
ever you know
but uh i understand defamation you know
is he he wanted to uh
he wanted to to you know justice i guess
and uh
that's how you get it right that's how
you do it so he's going to put it before
a judge
and uh we'll see what happens but it's
going to be interesting to follow
definitely i'm basically hitler
um this is the the quote unquote fake
dm
yeah
so i should say keemstar says this is
fake who put this out basher yeah
i don't i don't know that basher lied
about
stuff i'm not again i'm not super
familiar
with that story
but look i'm not brain martin if you
talk [ __ ] about me behind my back again
i'll have two interviews set up of
underage girls in chat logs i have done
nothing to you but since you want to
swing at me get ready to get killed i
have to say that's literally exactly how
keemstar talks
like i'll just say that i don't i mean
unless basher is like an absolute genius
uh
that's and the thing about like um he's
got this weird obsession with like if he
anyone slights him the least then i'ma
swing back he literally says that swing
back
seems real you know i just want to say
that i personally didn't hear him deny
but when i got an argument with someone
about it one of his goons they said that
he denied that that was real so
i don't know it was a long time ago so
so so he he denies that it's real but
based on my expertise uh sounds like
keemstar
and that's pretty and [ __ ] insane
thing to say thank you
because i got a [ __ ] files on top of
files to swing back at the keemstar even
has he responded he said something he
said he's going to take his play button
because famously the first time that kim
was sued by that guy um and won
um he
i don't even know how he game this if it
was like part of
settlement the settlement or whatever
but yeah he took the guy's youtube play
button
yeah so dj sued him for
uh defamation which was like a way way
weaker case than death noodles
and keemstar won on an anti-slap and
when you went on anti-slap you can
pursue legal fees
and
during the i guess settlement
talks he
he said that he won't sue for
attorney's fees if he hands over his
play button
which i have to say is kind of epic he
has the guys play but
um
yeah here it is i'm going to add another
play button to my collection you know
what's crazy i just hope because like
i don't know anything about defamation's
death noodles
it gets confusing there's a lot of
deaths being thrown around uh i don't
know anything about death noodles
lawyers but i hope they're [ __ ] good
but i
don't know what's his
what deaf noodles coffers look like
because
if the anti-slap
gets rejected
by the judge which would be good for
deaf noodles
then they're gonna have to do discovery
depositions it may
unlikely but it may go to a jury and
this could cost this is gonna cost him
hundreds of thousands of dollars so i
don't know what is going on i tried to
talk to death noodles and he's he
wouldn't tell me anything he was keeping
it like super close to the vest
so he's taking it really seriously i
just don't know
how far he can take this thing because
these are very expensive very very
expensive
i mean
if it was anybody but keemstar
i would say there's probably a good
chance they'll just settle but i feel
like keemstar will want to take take
this all the way
yeah no keemstar's not going to settle
right there's no shot no shot
um
unless he's
well if he's really losing and it's not
looking good they might make a
settlement arrangement but that's not
coming for a while
someone said how much does your legal
stuff cost man it's so much money i mean
my my attorneys are amazing i gotta say
my attorneys are like i love them
they're just
they're just so talented and good
and thorough wow thanks for the gifted
sub guys i just noticed 20 from ishaan
20. yeah and 10 from katherine that's so
nice thank you guys so much
love this gifted sub thing it's like
wait so how does that work
so how it works is someone buys
they can buy other fupa troopers
memberships
and we learned on
wednesday
that
youtube randomly gives it but they give
it to people who are most engaged with
the challenge so people who have a lot
of watch time are engaging they get
they're going to end up getting free
that's really cool memberships from
these uh very generous stupa troopers so
cool
yeah isn't that amazing yeah so shout
outs
um
my my legal fees are insane i mean you
can only imagine i'm being i got sued
four times
um you know i don't even keep track of
it anymore it's a lot it's a lot
but it's fine
you know what i mean
it's hard to keep track because there's
months where there's a lot of work to do
and then
a little bit of um waiting time or
something so
it goes up and down yeah but the good
thing is that
it looks like we're going to get our
attorney's fees back for the torches
interference one i haven't read a update
but it looked like they missed their
deadline for filing to dispute that so i
think they might have to fork over a fat
check to me for the tortious
interference which i'm gonna frame by
the way
i'm gonna blow that up and put it right
behind us and hopefully i'll have a
whole collection of them by the end of
this it's awesome
yeah
thank you oh so you can gift one someone
just gifted one thank you kiki kiki do
you love me are you dancing
so anyway it's going to be real
interesting to follow you know i hate
that it has to come to this with the
with a defamation lawsuit between
youtubers
i don't think it
is good that's i wouldn't say it's good
for the community you know
any legal precedent like that against
creators is probably going to be
just it's it's not going to be good you
know that you know when i'm [ __ ]
getting sued by ryan cavanaugh triller
or some [ __ ] like matt haas it's
great
uh it's can set great questions but you
have two creators
uh going at it trying to
you know
that's bad i don't know it's bad but
listen you can't define fame people
unfortunately kim's star has been at it
for years it was only a matter of time
before he got sued for defamation
yeah i mean
nothing nothing else seems to help you
know
i i get it definitely been talking about
it
it did everything but look the guy
didn't even remove the tweet like yeah
exactly he did the same exact thing to
me you know
the same exact thing his video's still
up about me
thank you guys for all the gifts and
donations love you all so much discovery
on kim's hairline please alexandra said
i'm gonna back you up on that one
so you know
all right we'll see what happens i'll
definitely be following and updating you
guys he said discovery on why he wore
all his clothes in the pool
that is we're going to need some
information yeah we're going to deep
dive on that
keemstar shut up
yeah but discovery will be interesting
because they're going to be able to
subpoena
every conversation he's had with his
goons privately about death noodles and
whatever they've been coordinating
amongst themselves
um and if he doesn't
you know if he doesn't give it up in
discovery he can be held uh
contempt yeah i think i think it's
illegal
and it was used in a book huh
um anyway we have our um
our guest today
that i talked about at the top of the
episode
jackson palmer
founder of dogecoin is with us
why don't we bring him in dan okay one
second i'm gonna queue it up
as you guys know deutsche dogecoin has
been huge
kind of a big deal you know uh
and it's been talked about the likes of
like elon musk pumped it
it was like one of the biggest kind of
cash grabby uh
kryptos i'm sure all of you guys heard
about dogecoin
and with us uh jackson is with us hi
jackson thanks for calling how's it
going hello
this is so cool to speak with you about
this i appreciate the opportunity to
talk with you about it
yeah
so um first of all let's just start from
the top like um where did the idea for
dogecoin
come from was it meant to be ironic from
its inception it seems like it
yeah i know for sure um it started in
like 2013 i
was like a lot of people like what the
heck is this this crypto nonsense and uh
there was every day there was like
something else coined and so i just
tweeted one day like uh i'm gonna invest
in dogecoin it's the next big thing kind
of just pulling it out of thin air i
think i'd had a couple of beers at the
time
um and i bought dogecoin.com and was
like as a parody cryptocurrency
um and so it was really a joke to make
fun of it but then
um you know a week later uh my now
co-founder who created it with me
reached out and was like oh we should we
could make it a real thing we could put
it put the dog logo on on top of bitcoin
and you know just to kind of continue
the joke and i was like sure
um
and so it really did start out as this
kind of really light-hearted just kind
of way to poke fun at crypto i've always
had a very skeptical kind of opinion of
crypto but then
as you all know it kind of uh got out of
hand a little bit
so did you guys actually put i i don't
did you guys put a lot of work into
creating dogecoin is that a lot of no
it's not no it was probably like
four hours tops that's
how does it work though because you have
to connect it to some kind of
doesn't need the process and you have to
have code and all this [ __ ] i don't know
how it works
yeah but it you can basically do a find
and replace in like the bitcoin source
code and just change it to dogecoin and
then you change a few numbers
you know you change the font to comic
sans and you put a dog on it and that's
that's it that's incredible it wasn't a
lot of work and and realistically
both of us um you know
who were both kind of skeptical he i
think he's a little less skeptical of
crypto these days but um we both thought
it would like be a joke for like a week
and everybody would forget about it
collectively but
so um
yeah i mean there was the doge meme was
really popular then with that like goofy
dog
and uh it was i remember seeing it on
reddit and everyone was just loving the
meme of it
and it was kind of weird because it
disappeared for a while
and then it came back like in a huge way
is that kind of what happened like if i
pull up the chart
yeah uh here let's pull up the chart of
it
let's see if i go it was um
there was kind of like a big wave like
that first crypto wave like 2014 yeah i
mean it was flat basically until all of
a sudden in
2021 in february
dude you shot up to freaking that was so
nuts it shot up to almost a dollar
yeah that was like crypto kind of goes
in these cycles where like
it's the same kind it's the same grift
it's just a different kind of angle
every every couple of years and so it
was like first it was like oh we're
going to replace the banks and then a
few years later it's like icos was the
big thing and then you know more
recently it's been around some of like
there was meme stocks and defy and nfts
and stuff like that and
i think that combined with the the like
elon effect um just like
shot it up but yeah i haven't been
actively involved in it since like 2014
so oh wow um
yeah so it doesn't require any
maintenance basically
from from the two of you who who founded
it it's just i don't know either neither
of us are involved in it anymore like
he's kind of i guess uh more of a the
face of it i would say like he interacts
with elon and stuff more but i um i very
quickly like after the joke got out of
hand kind of
realized like
who the the community of people in
crypto were and
um
tried my best to like educate people for
a while around like the technology and
the pitfalls of it but then i realized
that nobody really cared about that they
just cared about making a buck and so
yeah
so
just to give you guys an idea of how
insane dogecoin got
market cap right now and it's kind of
like
the lowest it's been since january it's
at 11 billion dude
that's insane that's so crazy from the
stoop
from this goofy joke you guys can you
explain what does this even mean to me
dummies like me it means that people who
own bitcoin there's 11 billion dollars
of people of real money like in the pool
of yeah
kind of kind of like i should just say
like when you look at those market caps
they're all really inflated because
what it means is like it's the total
supply that exists of that thing
multiplied by what people would
currently pay for it right now
but the reality is and we've seen this
all the time is that the second somebody
loses faith and starts selling then very
quickly the price will drop off and the
market cap will shrink so
it's not real money like when you say
that something's got like 100 billion
dollar market cap it's actually no like
that's assuming everybody would pay what
it's worth right now not if everybody
started running for the doors because
the thing was crashing got it so
basically
you created dogecoin
and it quickly got out of hand
what was your reaction to like
i mean
so people started investing in it but
i think like around january 21 is that
when elon musk started tweeting about it
or like what caused that first influx
yeah um well it was pretty big as well
like even back in the day in 2014 it was
still like you know in the top right
cryptos um so it was pretty big and
there was you know scandals and hacks
and all of that and you know my
co-founder and i we never kept any of it
for ourselves so we were kind of oh we
didn't have
a financial incentive you know because
it was a joke right you didn't you never
invested in dogecoin no
you could have made so much money do you
care about that
not really because if you put like if
you put like you know 100 bucks into
dogecoin when you made it
that would have been worth a lot right
yeah it's one of those things where like
i don't know i i feel like i'd have a
really messed up opinion of the world if
if i was like you know on a private jet
because of a dog on a coin so i'm
totally okay with not that not being the
case but
um no it was big for a while then there
were scams and stuff and uh i did a
youtube channel for a while with crypto
and stuff and then just completely wiped
my hand of crypto in like 2019
and then in the latest kind of run-up in
like 21 with nfts and stuff
when all that game stops stock stuff
game stonks happen um
i think uh elon and
um specifically there's a person that
works for elon who like manages his
whole like
all of his money for him um i think got
pretty involved um i was i don't know
the specifics because i wasn't there but
he just started like hammering tweets
about it and then that just like shot it
up
so you think what happened behind the
scenes is he he's like saw it as
opportunity to make easy money and just
bought a shitload and then started
tweeting about it i don't know i i can't
i'm not gonna i can't speculate but um
it it's well i can't speculate but i i
don't know
certainly that would be a really easy
way to make a bunch of money wouldn't it
it would be but like does he need the
money so like you know the thing the
thing with with with him i know you're
talking about him a little bit later is
that
um
i think ego matters to him more than
money and so i think
the cool thing for him about like
tweeting about
crypto stuff is that it helps him kind
of expand his like cult of personality
right like there's a lot of people that
are like totally on the elon train now
purely because he's like pumped their
crypto
and yeah i don't know if it's so much
about like him making like an extra buck
off of any kind of crypto token so much
as it is that's interesting him building
like a digital army of people who will
like fight to the death because they
think he's tony stark or something you
know well what's interesting about like
the anecdote anyways like if he did that
where he bought a bunch of dogecoin and
then started tweeting about it and the
price went up like you know ten thousand
percent that wouldn't be illegal would
it
i see that's the thing right like that's
the thing with cryptocurrency right um
it's
that
you know i've been in it for almost a
decade now and i i kind of believe and i
posted this on twitter last year that i
think crypto is is kind of it exists as
a way
to help people
um
kind of commit shady do some do some
shady [ __ ] and uh
kind of
shirk the responsibility of that because
there's no like it's a legal gray area
or the regulation just doesn't happen to
exist or
you know
um
so yeah i think in it like if he did
that with tesla stock he'd be in a
little bit exactly or any other stock
but i think with crypto he can you know
people can get away with that anybody
can so let me go back a little bit so
when you made this
did you what was your early skepticism
of crypto basically
it started off as um
it started off as just like when there's
when everybody's talking about something
and a lot of people that aren't very
technical are talking about something
that involves cryptography you know i
was kind of like this this feels like a
little bit of a bubble and so it was
more of a a general criticism of that
and
at first i tried to give it kind of the
benefit of the doubt and you know back
in the day there was actually some
some some people that i kind of aligned
with more politically like some occupy
people are involved and things like that
i was like oh okay maybe this is some
cool people that actually want to you
know change your power structures in the
world but
um
then as i was in it for more and more
years i just realized i was like oh no
like
this this is not those people those
people slowly got out of it and um it
increasingly just became you know the
people that came from like the online
gambling world or you know the the super
like right libertarian folks who
you know um want to create some kind of
you know
libertarian utopia on an island or
something you know and and i was like oh
like i see what this is actually about
uh now and so my my criticism kind of i
guess honed in um after i was in it for
a bit and so basically
um as you started seeing a lot of
gambling and kind of people who just
want to hide money basically from the
government
so
i've seen you have really skate i read
what you wrote on twitter and it was
really incredible i thought and really
and just pointed right like really
direct
um
was there was there a point somewhere
where
you're just like this thing is just
irredeemably [ __ ]
there was yeah like so
for the the longest time i was like you
know all these terrible people might be
involved but
um at the end of the day it's technology
and you know technology can be neutral
right um
and i think
when i got really deep into it in like
2018 with my youtube channel and i went
deep into the technicals of this stuff
what i quickly realized is that
um not only is the the promotion and the
hype you know kind of a grift but also
the technology itself is fundamentally
flawed it's it's it's very centralized
at like every layer of of the equation
and you know like
whether it's people that are using like
custodial wallets like coinbase or
metamask which like you know one company
is deploying into like chrome browsers
or whether it's people that are using
like openc.com which is a centralized
website um or even the blockchain which
is like powered by like a small number
of bitcoin miners and you know there's
you know huge centralization of the you
know people that own all the money on
those things like
the
the decentralization is really a facade
it's not real and the technology can't
really support a lot of what they claim
it can uh you know
but if you say it enough people start to
believe that something is true right
and so the decentralization is really a
lie and it's only useful to the
promoters of the technology in being a
really convenient facade that they can
kind of
you know make it harder to get caught
for the shady stuff they're doing
because they could say well you know
like i didn't manipulate it it's
decentralized um and a lot of people
turn a blind eye to that yeah because i
think
a lot of the enthusiasm for crypto in
the beginning
it was championed as like this new
uh
this new monetary system outside the
traditional system and it was returning
power to the people right and now we had
control and everything was transparent
um
anti like the bank right
anti-establishment [ __ ] the bank
that you know the few rich powerful can
no longer control our money
that's not happened has it
no no and it's it's interesting like i
was saying earlier that every few years
they have to change like the the pitch
because they they realize what they were
everybody's kind of cottoned on to what
they were saying you know so like it
used to be like yeah fight the power and
it will replace banks and then they
realize oh no it doesn't scale it can't
actually be a currency uh it's it's like
digital gold that's the next thing we'll
say it's like a store of value it's an
investment you know and then they
realize that actually it can drop half
its value overnight that's not like
goals right so they're like oh actually
it's an ico crowdfunding platform it's
it's way better than kickstarter what's
ico
ico was like initial coin offerings that
happened in like 2017 it was kind of
like kickstarter
and there was a lot of fraud there
but my point is that every few years
they change and they try to um come up
with a new pitch of of you know this
thing is going to democratize this it's
going to be great for the average joe
right and what they're really doing is
just lining up a new batch of suckers
who will put their money and
um and to your point about like
the the wall street thing like if it was
really about that then you wouldn't see
wall street and venture capitalists so
is so invested they love it i've noticed
that these guys love crypto why do you
think these wall street guys and these
huge investment bankers
and banks just banks love cryptos so
much
um i i like i think it's because well
i think it's mostly because it exists in
a world that isn't as regulated as the
world that they have increasingly had to
deal with in the last 30 years right so
the sec has cracked down you know since
the dot-com uh boom and then and then
the recession
um you can't do a lot of this
manipulation you can't have a lot of
these kind of back uh back room kind of
dealings in in in
with publicly traded companies and uh or
even even privately traded companies but
with the blockchain you can kind of
brush it all away and say well it's all
decentralized like i don't actually
control that it's in the ether somewhere
and so you can't catch me and and
realistically like regulators are like
asleep at the wheel like the fact that a
lot of the um you know scams have to be
exposed by citizen journalists like
coffeezilla on youtube
molly wyatt who runs web3 is going
great.com like
if the system was working then you know
those people would be getting outed by
the actual regular regulatory bodies but
instead average people have to do it so
to me that that's why venture
capitalists love it because they're like
this is great and there's no
accountability i mean like coffee zilla
you mentioned he like there's actual
straight-up fraud being committed by
influencers here who are well-respected
people in the community committing huge
acts of fraud
uh of millions of dollars and even after
they're totally exposed there's
literally no
there's no authoritative agency stepping
into to
to judicate like there's no
accountability even after it's been
exposed
there's absolutely no consequences and
so that's like why you know people ask
me why this stuff is so rife and i'm
like it's because there are literally no
consequences to you know all the stuff
that happened with like faze clan and
you know
like every day there's a new thing yeah
nobody ever gets in trouble and
i think that you know we've entered a
really interesting phase like where
it
there's a kind of moral nihilism that i
think is happening where people like
don't
care anymore
that's what i see a lot like i'm
thinking like even you guys are talking
about how there's no repercussions or
anything it's like it's actually even
beyond that they're seen as cool like
they game they're smarter than you
they're gaming the system and you're
behind so you're you're poor and stupid
and you should just like
admire what's happening that's so true
actually that's i was talking to
somebody the other day and the
difference that i've noticed in like you
know from back when dogecoin was first
created when i used to tell people
crypto is a pyramid scheme it's a ponzi
scheme this is like
this is really bad they would often
reply like oh that's just fud you know
like
you're you're making this up like you're
wrong they'd actually debate me but now
when i say you know crypto is a pyramid
scheme a lot of people actually respond
yeah we know
the whole world's a pyramid scheme
actually and it's cool it's so as long
as i'm making money out of it i don't
great yeah and that's just like that's
crazy to me it's such a
a change in the way that people don't
seem to care about the collective good
anymore yeah yeah i think the problem is
that like there's been an everything
bubble where you can't really lose on
investment for the past five years so
everybody's like it's all good
everyone's making money what's the
problem um
but that's i think that's going to
change big time here everything's you
know as we head to into a recession
but um
when you you talked about how they are
always making up a kind of a new
angle to pitch crypto to a new batch of
suckers when you say they is there's
people specifically that you think of
who are like perpetuating this
oh for sure yeah um i think it's a lot
of so a lot of the the vcs that are a
lot larger now started off as smaller
vcs back in the day and we're investing
in companies like coinbase the krakens
the you know all the different exchanges
and the exchanges are really the only
companies that still
exist that existed back then because you
know that's how you make money right you
take a slice off the top of everybody
trading something
um you kind of can't lose and so um
i think it's it's really a
a concerted effort by the exchanges and
by
uh the the investors that were behind
those exchanges to come up with a new
narrative over time
and that's in the exchanges best
interest because
if you
if you incur get more people in the
exchanges make more money because the
way they make money is transaction fees
like they take a slice off the top right
and i think a good example of this is i
don't know if you've seen this but on
coinbase
um if you go in there they actually have
a whole system where they will pay you
to sit and
basically go through glorified ads about
like so and so token and this this other
crappy token like and you'll get paid
money um in that token by the way to
to essentially gamble it's a casino
essentially and they're giving you some
free money
and and they love it because they they
they build that kind of gambling
addiction up with this person under the
guise of decentralized education and
then they start taking a slice off the
top of every trade that that person does
as they become a day trader um yeah
so
um i'm curious what do you think there's
people like these financial self-help
gurus like it seems like every single
one of them is now in crypto yeah and to
them it's a revolution every if you
listen to garyvee for example
uh crypto is going to change the world
he's getting a crypto restaurant he's
doing these v friends which i'm sure
you've seen uh he says cryptocurrency is
going to be in video games there's going
to be an uh everything our license are
going to be on crypto
everything our whole world is going to
surround uh uh be surrounding crypto
what do you think about someone like
garyvee
i i think yeah he and a lot of these
other financial youtubers and people
like that um
shameless self plug i'm doing a podcast
right now called griftonomics and it's
all about you know these different
topics
i'm interested in that
the first episode was on web3 uh check
it out but um i'm going to do an episode
on on these kind of people specifically
because
years ago they they were all about
selling tickets to their kind of
self-help conferences right now that
made a bit of money for them
um and and now they've all pivoted
really quickly into like nfts web three
um
with a a total disregard for any like
they don't understand the technology i
actually saw gary vee is running a
conference today um and uh he got up and
he was he was saying you we're going to
give you all fractional ownership in
this nft which doesn't make any sense
because like non-fungible means it's not
fractional so
the guy is just
you know a grifter of you know
the highest highest pedigree thank you
for saying that because i've been saying
that for years and people they love gary
vee they love him even here on this
personality i don't i don't judge the
people that like him but i feel like
he's such a grifter and it's great like
this viewfriends thing's the most
shameless cash grab it's i can't [ __ ]
believe whatever not to mention it's
like the ugliest eye ever like that's
the real thing that's why anybody it's
like can we make it look better like
what is all this ugly stuff that
everybody's buying and i'm not i'm not
judging anyone that likes garyvee i just
think it's interesting because
listen i mean i guess the thing is gary
vee had us a whole stick before crypto
that i think people really liked
uh he makes out with his dad i don't
know if you've seen that that's an
interesting thing uh but a separate
issue
but like you're making an nft of that
right absolutely
absolutely
um but you know uh
you know it's just he i saw him talking
about how he's like i made three million
dollars in my sleep last night just from
selling v friends
um
i don't know man it's just i think what
it is is he sells the
it's that cult of personality where you
sell the the dream that
not only am i like you know gary vee i'm
a multi-millionaire but you could be too
yeah and i think that's what gets people
really suckered into it and i think it's
the same with elon i think there's a lot
of people out there that huge elon
stands that think that you know by
you know spamming his replies they that
he might become friends with them and
then maybe they'll be able to kind of
you know be a a rocket scientist or
something and
um
yeah real culty
yeah cause he just posts he posts dumb
memes and they like dumb memes they're
they could be best buddies
um that's interesting
but do you think like gary vee's uh
crypto
utopia
d like decoupled from
coins
he's like we're going to be using the
blockchain to govern everything in our
life do you see the blockchain
technology being anything interesting in
that regard or is it just dumb
i i think it's um
years and years and years ago i
thought maybe it could have had legs as
something but like i said when you when
you actually like look under the covers
and you look at
at the technology you start to realize
that it it just isn't
created in a way that scales to the way
that we would need to do governance as a
society at a mass scale like it works at
the scale of like some scammer like
taking a few thousand people's money but
it doesn't scale up to like a place
where you could run a country on it or
anything like that
um and then you start to think about
like the environmental concerns a lot of
these blockchains still haven't migrated
away from proof of work right it's
hugely hugely negative for the the
environment but then even worse in my
mind is is that
you're switching you know
i think a lot of people as well that
lean on the on the political left as
well would agree that it would be great
to have you know less less state control
in some ways and and have a breakaway in
some sense but
to do that you have to actually create a
new system which which breaks away the
power structures and the hierarchies
that exist but crypto doesn't do that
that's the problem is what they've
essentially done is just recreated a
version of of the same system we have
but instead of the government being the
boot you're now licking the boot of the
venture capitalists and they control the
power so yeah i don't think it you know
that's not a world i want to live in and
i think um
until there's a way that you can somehow
with some magic technology prevent that
from happening i i don't think that it
has a real world use case
by the way just remember we actually did
already make this at nft
if you're interested i know you're not
interested in web3 and stuff but
can you see that
yes
yes so this is frenching fathers we
actually made this
oh god a month or two ago
and it is on the blockchain if anyone's
interested
um is this available for purchase ian i
know i never sold it yeah maybe you just
put it up i mean this is history
oh it was never it was never actually
it's just uh actually and
what's interesting is we did it in the
art style we tried to emulate garyvee's
artistic uh
talents as well gorgeous
i will it looks nicer than garyvee it is
a little more technical i think
yeah what love
oh it's just i mean it's i think it's up
but i think it technically so nobody's
bid on this thing
oh there's multiple bids actually if you
scroll down it gets minted when you sell
it pretty much when you accept a offer
the best offer we got was point zero one
two
is that eth
yeah i mean come on guys this is
this is a once in a lifetime opportunity
garyvee sells this [ __ ] for hundreds of
thousands of dollars right this is way
cooler
yes so um
so in short i don't know i mean
is it are we just basically waiting for
an inevitable crash to zero is that
where you think this is going
i don't know i was having this
conversation with somebody yesterday and
i was like is that the only way all of
this ends um and maybe but i
i i've gotten out of the habit of
predicting when things are going to
implode because it i do think there's a
lot of people in power that are
motivated to to keep on uh
keeping the train going and
and i
sadly i think that that will often come
in the way of that that only affects the
the people that are you know lower on
the on the socioeconomic rung um they're
the people that might lose millions of
dollars because they bought a stupid v
friend um you know they'll lose their
401ks because the bottom falls out of
all of this um meanwhile do i think the
venture capitalists will be lining up
the next batch of people with whatever
the next nft craze is absolutely and i i
think
i i really don't think unless there's
some
unless it really really crashes or
unless regulation comes in and and the
government actually kind of you know
wake up and say oh this might be bad
that people are losing their 401k so
that um it becomes an issue i i think
there is a bit of a little bit of light
at the end of the tunnel for that in
that
the previous big crypto crashes we had
before
crypto wasn't as
ingrained in some of traditional finance
as it is today and so back in like 2018
when there was a crash you didn't have
people with their 401ks invested you
didn't have people that had taken out um
you know mortgages on their homes to buy
bitcoin as to the level that you do
today and so
a lot of people have actually
hypothesized that a crypto crash might
actually trigger a larger global uh
financial crash um and that would be
really interesting to to see right it
would force it would force more scrutiny
but yeah exactly that could bring about
more people like oh wow that was a
problem we have nobody's called it out
except everybody did you know
right well yeah i'm surprised that the
i would have to assume that there's
someone in the fed who's
putting together something right like
there's got to be
someone looking at this it's been going
on long enough
i mean just scam after scam after scam
after scam after scam by huge people
people that peop that say hey
you know that guy is a has a great
reputation we love him he just [ __ ]
scam someone for millions of dollars
there's got to be someone looking at
that right
i i would hope so i honestly my faith is
a little shaken having been in it for
the last 10 years and not seen a lot a
lot happen so
i think something will have to hit
closer to home like maybe maybe a
lawmaker will have to lose money some
way through something they've invested
in ted cruz is going to lose all of it
all of his cancun coins
yeah exactly
well
there you have it folks
uh
to the moon
what's your favorite [ __ ] coin what's
your like we have safe moon that was a
good one we had uh big connect what's
your favorite uh scam or the craziest
scam you've seen to date
oh you know what it was years ago and i
i i'm always like a little hesitant to
say this because i worry that i'm giving
something like a platform but
may i think it's dead enough now that i
can talk about it there was a coin in
like 2017 2018 called dentacoin
and it was a cryptocurrency
created purely to pay dentists in
so it's like
a bunch of these dentists i think
they're all in florida which you know
isn't super surprising together
to and they said yeah all of our dental
agencies will all start accepting this
coin this is the coin for dentists wow
and uh
can you believe it didn't work out can
you believe that
global currency here's the dentacoin
website
so they actually got dental people to
sign up and they work so i think they
did i i didn't validate whether any
dentist actually accepted it but that's
the weirdest thing i ever heard
god that is just so bizarre
how is that easier than just paying with
dollars
yeah you tell me
that's the case with all of it right
i guess if you're like i only own
bitcoin
then you can buy dentacoin
weird man
that's so weird what's dentacoin worth
today i wonder
hopefully not too much
uh total unlocked there is good news
guys
there is uh what is this
so this is million billion so there's
2.1 trillion dentacoin
unlocked
out of a max supply of
golly
7.3 trillion
so there's plenty left to know
yeah actually i have a root canal later
it's gonna cost me a hundred billion
identical
so that that's a good currency to use
for that i can't wait for the headline
tomorrow dogecoin creator pumps
dentacoin
heavily invested pump dentacoin oh this
shit's going to the moon
well thanks for calling thanks for
sharing your story
is there anything else you kind of want
to leave the people with uh who are
wondering about crypto
we're thinking about crypto no people in
crypto
i would just say like make sure you you
know go out and think twice before
somebody promises you something just
because it's got some fancy acronyms
next to it doesn't mean it's it's it's a
worthwhile investment and uh
yeah i i uh like i said i'm doing that
podcast and if people want to follow it
along i'm going to have some more stuff
on on crypto and metaverse and
all that stuff again actually going to
do something on i know you and uh
comrade hassan were talking about online
gambling yesterday yeah i'm gonna do an
episode on that like twitch gambling and
like the skull steak the steak uh yeah
it's just all crypto so shady so [ __ ]
really nuts yeah so
anyway check it out if you're interested
in
this
give a [ __ ] yeah
economics
drifting that's just griftonomics on
twitter as well grift o nomiks there you
go
follow
uh i throw it in the description sounds
really interesting yeah um thank you to
jackson palmer
thanks for having me on thank you
appreciate it thanks for calling in it
was really great to hear from you
grifton thanks people let's check it out
thanks man appreciate it
there you have it
jackson
the creator of dogecoin says crypto is a
giant scam
it's
nice to hear this kind of conversation
and i feel like
for some reason it doesn't make me feel
stupid like i can follow and understand
no you don't understand it's
revolutionizing the whole world it's
like the internet back when people
thought that was crazy you don't
understand it's not just a ponzi yo
you're in trouble that crypto [ __ ]
yeah but you know
so
there you go
it's pretty incredible man if that guy
though i know he i know he thinks it's a
scam but if he put a thousand into doge
when he made that bro he'd be like a
hundred millionaire or something crazy
that's the only thing he meant but he's
better yeah
the only reason he made a good point
though if he would be flying on a
private jet right now because of a dodge
coin
what would his life be he'd drink the
kool-aid yeah
he'd be like yo he'd be pretty he'd be
no you know what he'd be doing he'd be
asking the flight attendant if you can
buy a horse for it
nice lead in nice segway
um what an interesting story you know
interesting guy
ah yeah that crypto stuff is is is kind
of scary i wonder if a jimmy lee accepts
a dentacoin
he's missing out that's a really good
question
i'll have to ask him yeah
yeah good lead in let's talk about the
these huge
elon musk accusations that dropped
um
yesterday
and the whole timeline of this is
[ __ ] great you know
basically
he's been tweeting non-stop about how
he he comes out as republican
the day before what was the timeline
here it's it's so
what
what he came out as republican three
hours after
um being contacted
by the reporters and asking for comment
on these sa
allegations and uh declared himself a
republican and warned of dirty tricks to
come against him oh here's the timeline
yeah this person wrote it up it was
really good
he goes elon historically donated to
both democrats and republicans
uh you know
use unionization efforts started gaining
steam nationwide
which
has a negative effect on his business
debatable you know you want your workers
to be happy right yeah and i get there
on who
i just say maybe his bottom line but
i think more productive workers probably
do better work but
hey i'm not i don't own tesla
um business insider journalists
contacted him for comment
on an essay piece before
they published it
and then elon quickly spams tweets about
how political attacks are coming
and it's the woke left's fault he
literally started tweeting three hours
after being contacted
so as this insider piece comes out
he's actually successfully convinced
people
that this is a political smear because
he came out as republican i've seen so
many people including the quartering who
i i have i know he's dumb but can you be
that dumb to be like
just he he literally was like 24 hours
after he came out as republican the
smears are already coming what's funny
about that is that the other way around
well what exactly is so obvious so
obviously
it's always done like that
they always reach out to you a little
bit before try to get a comment it's
like you know it's coming they said they
even extended the deadline to give them
more time but what's interesting about
this is this incident happened six years
ago
and this conversation he's been having
with business insider
obviously predates his
proclamation that he's a republican it's
so obvious spin
that you have to be the
i mean some people don't follow all of
it so i i can understand people follow
you but the quartering i know he's dumb
but like you can't be that dumb
like he literally tweeted only 24 hours
later and they're already going after
him i was like
pull that tweet up would you it goes
back to what we were just talking about
he built this cult like following
and so they're already so deep invested
in every little tweet that he makes yeah
he's got an army i agree
because all the quarterings fans love
elon he doesn't want to go against the
family but he knows he knows
i don't know it's all dumb
he's got to know
so the story is and i read the article
god he looks like such a [ __ ] villain
in this photo doesn't he
i seen this photo of him i'm just like
dude
what the [ __ ] bro
such a pasty little freak
we don't need to make fun of his looks
right
he's a villain
it's a pasty little [ __ ] duh anyway
okay fine no phys no making fun of his
looks okay
uh
so what happened was
allegedly
a flight attendant for spacex
alleges that elon musk asked her to do
more during massage
straight out of the epstein playbook
pretty interesting how it's always the
massage she accused musk
uh oh here's the
is this the quartering one what was the
name of the um
that uh epstein dock that was like
specifically about his like activity
yeah i saw that house in uh palm beach
was on netflix what was it um god i
don't remember somebody in the chat what
was it called
filthy rich filthy rich was that what it
was called yeah yeah um yeah i mean the
description of the allegation is
i think literally exactly the same
that epstein was doing at that house in
palm beach right they talk about how he
would um they had this whole system to
go and get young girls to come over to
their house to give him a massage and
then basically it would escalate into
exactly sexual massage
but this is what elon's doing now to
deflect the attacks against me should be
viewed through a political lens this is
their standard despicable he's talking
more and more like trump it's pretty
incredible totally playbook but nothing
will deter me for fighting for a good
future and your right to free speech
uh
like
is is an nda
nda work with free speech just curious
because this he made them sign an nda
i'll tell you one thing that's not
disputed
he paid this girl 250 000 to shut up
so is nda how does nda
mesh with free speech i'm confused not
well it seems to be a contract it's part
of the story isn't it because um
there is like
in here in l.a
they're working on making that now
they're working on changing the law so
that nda when it comes to sexual
misconduct won't be right that's why
some people speculate he moved to texas
because of that they can no longer use
ndas
and settlements for
sa stuff which is really interesting law
actually
and uh all of a sudden elon musk can't
wait to get out of california
interesting
um
so anyway let's continue also here's the
quartering tweet just show you what
absolute [ __ ]
[ __ ] he is
like you know when i first read this i
was like oh he even quartering sees
through this but then i saw
i haven't seen what he said so here's
the headline uh spacex flight attendant
said elon musk exposed himself and
propositioned her for
sex uh document show the company paid
her 250 000 for silence uh quartering
says the day after he say he's voting
republican not even 24 hours later by
the way the dude was having a threesome
with amber heard and knocking up grimes
elon bags his own [ __ ]
see that's the problem they all like
idolize him so much
you can't do no wrong it's like
it's just crazy what he managed to
create it really is a cult
um
so
yeah there are people that dumb out
there
it's pretty incredible so it says that
elon
exposed his you know fully torqued
member to her
was rubbing her leg without consent i
guess i should give a trigger warning
people are sensitive to this stuff too
late i already said the worst part
basically
and this is kind of the interesting part
offering to buy her a horse
in exchange for an erotic massage
now i was like i was wondering is that a
good deal is that a good trade a horse
for a
handy i mean well you want to actually
get into that so
what's more interesting to me about this
story is also she was a flight attendant
okay and they pushed her into getting
lessons on becoming a masseuse
so she can give her massages so she
would be booked on more flights
and they encouraged her to do it on her
own time and her own money
here's the quote from the article they
encouraged her to get a license out of
the masseuse but on her own time on her
own dime they implied that she would get
to fly more often if she were to do this
because she would be able to give elon a
proper massage
i thought it was kind of strange because
she wasn't hired to be a masseuse she
was hired to be a flight attendant
that's the kind of the epstein
yeah the epstein i mean slide you're the
richest person in the world you think he
can hire the best masseuse
in the world
no he wants them to do it
pretty interesting right
but um no but back to actually the
really important question is a horse a
good is that a good payment well then
okay so the reason i i was going to
answer that is that
she kind of started to lose her shifts
so yeah oh yeah once she so it's not
just the horse payment it's really like
yeah probably the horse was a good deal
because she could have also kept her job
it's not just the horse yeah
but yeah after she reached after she
said no
they cut her hours
and basically fired her because she
wasn't wanting to play ball he knew that
she was into horses so she he said he'd
buy her horse no but seriously how much
the horse caused i just want to know the
economics of this seeing anywhere
from 3 250 000.
yeah i think it just depends on the
breed seabiscuit you ain't buying their
siblings
[Music]
i don't think it's a good deal well then
you got to take care of a horse
she it sounds like she would would be
the person that would want a horse based
on what she said yeah yeah she was into
horses so yeah i mean but
no that's not a good deal because um
she's not a masseuse
she's a flight attendant and that would
really lower her value as a person
right right right that's the serious
answer so if she actually has a job and
if she gets a salary every month she can
buy her own a horse right that's the
serious answer thank you self-esteem and
be
you know nothing wrong with giving
handies though if you want to if that's
what you're into yeah but if you don't
want to and you're coursed into it
that's bad yeah but i'm just saying if
she wasn't getting to giving hand dudes
he could do better than a horse that's
all i'm saying
i'm just trying to make a joke you're a
guy i'm trying to make it i know i know
you are but i i get i get so let's see i
get so rolled up about stories like that
oh you're right i can't even make a joke
you're right but i mean horse seat maybe
he should have offered her horse semen
because i know that's very valuable
right actually the most valuable uh
liquid on earth but per ounce
so maybe that's
dogecoin should probably go for that
dogecoin yeah
like a you know a load of sea biscuits
jizz is like more valuable than gold by
far semen tastes good so maybe he should
offer that just saying
just saying just saying
just saying so yeah i mean
let's see i got some intel on this um
an analysis of one of the major siemens
sellers
hundreds of horses on file
show an average of 900 per dose
so i guess a load of semen is only worth
900.
yeah still impressive yeah i mean if you
start selling
a few a day maybe high volume price by
volume you know it's very valuable and
it's just the right height and if that
seaman is really good and you and you
breed if they're a world champion
uh winner the roi on that semen is crazy
off the charts when can we get horse
semen coin
just saying
i mean gold has a gold is a commodity
why isn't horse team in a commodity like
that's a good store of value
anyway just making jokes here guys don't
get mad at me
so he offered to buy her a horse
everyone's so mad at me right now i'm
not i'm not real i'm not hurting anybody
i'm just kidding i don't think so
just saying though
it is interesting i love that
it's such an interesting question
um
so yeah basically she got less and less
time
and space x paid her 250 thous
as part of a severance agreement that's
a lot better than a horse yeah just
saying
unless it was seabiscuit right
without it but that's more seabiscuit is
more than that
seabiscuit jizz
i think
that was an average what he cited yeah
that was the average type how much how
much is it for for world class horses i
think
i think one of the most expensive was
secretariat
yeah how much was that i'm sure we can
find it sounds like he was just offering
a horse like any
horse
i don't otherwise they would have
mentioned the name you know if it was
like i'm going to buy you the i'm going
to buy you seabiscuit baby yeah
i don't know what i'm typing i know
how much is a seabiscuit
say world most expensive horse seaman
i'm sure
yeah
don't be don't be ashamed uh av
don't be embarrassed
yeah
uh
oh i had drum roll zack
ready drum roll supposedly winning big
star seamen
is 4.7 million
for one load wealthy investors are
willing to pay high prices for a proven
winner seaman
4.7 million for one load i'm sure the
the horse though just won the kentucky
derby i'm sure his his loads will be uh
worth a pretty penny
dude
that's nuts man can you imagine if
someone paid you five million dollars to
jerk off that's awesome let me find
applied to people like uh
semen of like the smartest person in the
world yeah einstein semen [ __ ]
valuable can you imagine if you had
einstein semen people be crazy about
that that'd be very what about elon musk
seaman that should be pretty valuable
yeah people would pay for that all right
this is theoretical well you get it for
free over 20 million dollars worth of
semen
in eight months if she was really
unconfused the play would be to like
i'm not gonna go there yeah use your
imagination from everywhere in my room
okay dude
stop stop using that can i suggest an
owl or something next time uh love what
is going on with your cup
like my cup what is this this was a sam
just handed it to me
this was a genius idea who's sam
the uh frozen cup there's like gel
inside oh that's awesome because we got
some complaints about ethan chewing on
the ice
oh
are you serious that's why you got this
yeah also oh my god really big
so it's just kind of funny how it makes
it so you guys wow i was wondering i
love
i love this wow i'm really stopped i
really need that much handling
you guys have to go how would that apply
to chewing gum
we got to get him an iv for food baby
steps
[Laughter]
very interesting okay
wow
i really am a pathetic [ __ ]
baby
cheers everybody
i'm not go
another thing we're saying the sound of
the ice clinking on the glass and the
mic was annoying okay um
thank you guys always thinking of the
show
thank you guys so much incredible stuff
um
so
the weird there's a weird twist on this
story i'm not gonna lie
that i feel like i would be remiss not
to mention
i don't think business
insider i don't think they have a great
track record of reporting
i don't think i'm the first one to point
that out and there's one really weird
detail
about
[Music]
this article
is that the story is reported
from the stewardess
friend
they never even because she's signed an
nda right so it could be
that they're just trying to bypass the
nda but in the article they say
this story is reported from the
masseuse's friend
and she didn't even ask permission
from the friend to share
this story
and so while i understand it's probably
a sidestep of nda so that she doesn't
get in trouble
that's some [ __ ] dog [ __ ] reporting
in my opinion like that that i don't
know that is like the
the ground is so
like if you're gonna call into question
the
validity of the reporting it's like
the person it happened to wasn't even in
the article she didn't even speak a
great idea on that
it just seems questionable what does dan
think
yeah what does dan think
what do i think well i mean
i i don't know obviously i'm not saying
my read on it my read on it is that
um
the most likely scenario is this woman
did want to come forward but couldn't
that's why and this was the way to get
around i understand but like in terms of
like solid reports yeah no because
obviously that he he's already using
that as a way to deflect and and his
defenders are using his way to deflect
and you're you're not wrong
the optics of that is it's not great but
also to be a victim of daddy mask musk
nobody wants that and
i feel like this is the only way for her
to bring this story out like how else
would you do that there's a reason
business insider broke this and not the
new york times or the washington post
it's because it's embarrassing it's
embarrassing if that's your source is
the i'm just saying it's like it's but
it's it's not like the story is fake it
doesn't sound like it there's the
payment that was made right yes the the
element of the fact that there is an nda
and a settlement that happened um
i believe her a modicum of uh it's like
so if you believe her then i think you
should
open with that because what you're
saying is kind of like putting the whole
story into question
what i'm saying is
i do believe her
but it's becomes pretty it just becomes
relatively
toothless and looks more like a
political hit
or a cash grab on business insider side
when they don't have like solid
reporting
it's like well her friend told me this
we haven't even talked to her it's like
okay
like if [ __ ] dan came to you and was
like yo my friend you know i'm just
saying it's not good reporting i believe
her i'm just saying it's [ __ ]
business insider but what it's just
gonna give him and all of his supporters
uh like every out possible to say what
can what can she do if she did want the
story out but she signed an nda nothing
but yeah no i don't think anything you
know and what's interesting is like you
know i'm just i'm get i'm trying to be
i'm just trying to give it impartial i
think it's important to say it's a big
angle in the story it's like it's what
his defenders are i mean i realizing
yeah i read the whole article and i was
taken aback
when it ended with that i was like what
i was like what the [ __ ] her friend
is the source of this and they never
even spoke to her that just struck me as
odd
that's all i'm saying it's not like but
i have to say that it's not like they
didn't confirm the story they're not
just reporting on something the person
said and that's it they literally said
we have not talked to that person okay
but the the paperwork and stuff are
there to back up the story it's not
right that yeah
somebody came and told us this and we're
telling you that yeah i mean they
corroborate it and that they i think
they corroborated it and that there was
a settlement paid for 250 to this girl a
severance and that's basically all
they're able to confirm and it's all
based on a friend's account again i
believe her it just seems like you know
pretty
pretty bad reporting that's all in the
nda um you know
her unwillingness to speak on this um
because they did correct me if i'm wrong
but they did say that they tried to
speak with her but she
wanted nothing to do with it it wasn't
that they didn't reach out to her well
we can pull up the article no i think i
mean i read last time that was my
understanding but i i could be wrong on
that um i mean but
um regardless uh you know the truth is
they could get [ __ ] sued into
oblivion by elon musk if they if like
the reporting is that thin you know
i wouldn't they married by the way i was
i was looking at the author i was like
please don't i was like bro cat wrote
this for sure
uh no it wasn't cat
it's just saying would have been funny
uh
let's see it ended with the friend told
insider oh no at least
what's interesting though is one of the
go-to defenses that elon has deployed um
was
if this were true uh describe my dick
oh pull that up yeah um
which it's like
all right it's a pretty cynical thing to
say when you have this person under an
nda like
she can't
say anything about that um so it's but i
mean i i understand why he said it
because it's like
you know describe describe a scar or a
tattoo he probably has a normal looking
dick i mean how do you describe that
like not everyone's got a crazy looking
dick like harvey weinstein right epstein
had like wild looking dicks apparently
right but regard
right that's a good point uh but anyway
he said but so let me read you just
to touch on this important point i think
they said insider is aware of her
identity
insider is also aware of the flight
attendant's identity but we're not
naming her because she's claimed to be
the victim of essay
she declined to comment for this story
the victim now also read this sex herb
the friend told insider that she decided
to come forward without consulting
with the flight attendant i think she's
doing it for her friend to not put her
at risk because of the nda right that's
that's possible but that's not what it
says i'm just saying
right if you're talking about the if you
want yeah that's that's that's the best
guess right
it says she says as a survivor i felt
obligated to share what i had been told
and then they specifically say unlike
the flight attendant her friend is not
bound by any non-disclosure agreement
that's what insider wrote
um
i just i was kind of blown away by that
line i was like whoa
that's weird
uh
so
there you have it
that's just a weird twist on it
and i don't think any other huge
publication
like i said there's a reason business
insider broke the story there's nobody
else talking about it they broke the
story okay everybody went to new york
times first talking about it
oh i mean yeah now it's well now that
they've worked it then everyone else can
report it
you know
report on their reporting yeah yeah
exactly but what so let's go back to
um
let's go back so
elon wrote
on twitter well first when they called
him for for a comment
he gave them a really interesting
response he said there's much more to
the story that's what he told insider so
he didn't actually deny it which i
thought was kind of damning and weird
mm-hmm
um but now so that's what he told
insider and then what happened
but also he said there's more to the
story that's like what every guilty
person always says just wait until you
hear it from my point of view
yeah just wait until the the truth is
revealed
no it's total it's totally incriminating
mm-hmm it's like it also just makes i
mean i know he obviously didn't mean it
this way but it makes him sound like
he's saying oh yeah there's a lot of
girls like this yeah there's a there's
so much more of this story obviously he
didn't mean that but i heard it as
that's why he he should have just not
said anything what i heard it as is this
definitely happened
that's what i heard and then another
interesting detail in the article
that corroborates it or is interesting
is that at the mediation with the flight
attendant musk personally attended it
right right i read that that's pretty
crazy
uh here's the tweet i was talking about
by the way how would they get all this
information if they didn't do proper
research on the story
i think the friend provided all that i
mean they confirmed it but
i don't think they did much research and
just being honest i think they got all
they corroborated the info
just saying you know
musk
responded he's on twitter he said i have
to challenge
i have a challenge to this liar
who claims their friend saw me expose
describe just one thing anything at all
scars tattoos that isn't known by the
public she won't be able to
so because it never happened you know
what that tells me that's such a bad
response you know that tells me you
could go and get a tattoo right now and
say this was there and she didn't call
it out like what it tells me that he's
been
specifically ready to use this excuse
when this happened inevitably because he
doesn't have tattoos he doesn't have
distinction he's being advised by our
lawyer from tick tock he's saying
go and say you drank afterwards you
weren't drinking while you were driving
totally it's like the same logic
afterwards
and she didn't know about that tattoo
being there so she wasn't there yeah but
if i was like
a crustial guy who's been doing this for
a while
and i like my me i don't have any
tattoos i don't have any markings on my
body i don't have anything weird going
on with my penis
just saying right i wouldn't know how to
describe it it's like regular and then
like so what is there to say
in detail in that uh bobby lee episode
the other day
i described it in detail oh
i don't know how much detail i described
it in but
um but it's a it's a normal looking
penis is my point and so this challenge
is so obscene it's disgusting one and
two it's like a [ __ ] joke i mean it's
so ridiculous um
it's just doesn't prove anything you
know i don't know i i just feel like
this is not the response for somebody
who didn't do it
no and he actually took it further he
said
um what's this one here i've highlighted
is this what he wrote or did he tweet
this
this is how he responded to insider he
said this is what he told insider if i
were inclined to engage in
essay or sh
this is unlikely to be the first time in
my entire 30-year career that it comes
to light he wrote calling the story a
politically
motivated hit piece
i mean
it's funny if you take what the
quartering said and responses like that
it makes way more sense when you look at
him coming out as a republican saying
political hits are coming against
right before this story comes out like
that's so [ __ ] obvious the attacks
against me he tweeted should be viewed
through a political lens this is
standard a we already read
yeah
i hate how at the end it's like uh
everything i'm doing is for you
i'm doing more for the world than any
human alive
just let me not follow the rules
i'm doing so much for you come on come
on actually i do think they actually
have that opinion when you become that
billionaire and you have that such an
inflatable you go you go i am saving
humanity i'm not supposed
the least you could do is give me a hand
job the rules do not apply to
billionaires you can rationalize a
million a million ways like
like i'm not going down for a [ __ ]
hand job like i'm too important you know
and he's probably correct i mean epstein
did it for like no his whole life and
yeah and epstein nobody even liked that
guy to begin with right
good luck with the elon
but you know it's just interesting
to see it all kind of playing out
um
i don't know if there's anything else
really elon asked her to come in his
room
uh for
a
full body massage
when she arrived the attendant found
that he was completely nude except for a
sheet covering his lower half of his
body
during the massage
musk exposed his
genitals and then touched her and
offered to buy her a horse to do more
it's awesome the horse thing is just so
[ __ ] weird
bizarre
although epstein only paid him like 20
bucks or something so
very uh
uh genghis khan
yeah issuing horses
the old horse for a handy yeah
it's also this kind of like he's so rich
he goes everyone's got a price
everybody's got a price
he probably thinks i can get a hand job
from anybody
well would you get would you jerk him
off for a billion dollars
oh
do a lot more
that's what i'm saying yeah exactly
everyone has this price he's right he
just went too low with the horse
honestly he should have given her cash
force and a staple
right the stable would have come
the stable could have sealed the deal
i'm kidding guys please come on don't
[ __ ] kill me here
please come on
just saying
uh so
yeah so again
uh
in 2008
um
after becoming convinced that her
refusal to accept musk's proposal had
diminished her opportunities at space x
the attendant hired a lawyer and sent a
complaint to the hr department
around that time the attorney's firm
contacted the friend
and asked her to prepare a declaration
the attendance complaint was resolved
quickly
after a session with a mediator that
musk personally attended i find that
very interesting
he went there in person that's pretty
intense he's a busy guy with a huge
inflated ego you know he doesn't show up
to [ __ ]
unless it's important
um
the matter never reached a court of law
or even arbitration
in november 2018 musk spacex and the
flight enter attendant entered into a
severance agreement for 250 thous
in exchange never to sue and i'm sure it
had a nice juicy the agreement also
included a very restrictive nda
and non-disparagement clause
that barred the attendant from ever
discussing
the severance payment or disclosing any
information of any kind about musk
or any of his businesses
and this is really interesting just
months after her settlement in 2018 the
government jerry brown then the governor
of california
signed into law the stand against
non-disclosure act which bars the use of
nda's
going forward in settlements involving
uh you know
sh discrimination or assault
unless they are requested by the
plaintiff
now what's the timeline of of
musk wanting to leave california
it was a few years later and like yeah i
didn't know about that bill it's pretty
cool
i i
i mean
i even said that last night when we were
talking about it somewhat facetiously of
well this is why he wanted to leave
texas um
but
um
because you know i think it had much
more to do with um
them trying to
uh close his factories during the covet
outbreak and everything and him being
unwilling to do that and you know that
makes more sense for him to move out of
california
uh he was getting triggered the timing
is interesting that you know
no more sexual harassment ndas and dude
they're great later he's out dude the
guy runs a huge manufacturing plant that
relies on robots
and texas can't even [ __ ]
keep their grid online like it's just
it's not that advantageous to be there
i'm just saying
um so he so again remember when insider
called him
he said
there's more to the story but now on
twitter
he's denying it outright he says where
were these wild accusations against elon
musk before he took a stand against the
establishment when did he do that when
did he take a stand against the
establishment i must have missed that
tweet
he is the establishment dude you're the
richest person in the world like who are
you taking a stand against exactly god i
missed that that when that happened he
stood against the establishment
exactly he says
[ __ ] the fact that he is
like
echoing this kind of like replying to
comments like this and totally saying
exactly it's just all part of like his
building total spin colt
yeah and for the record like nobody
normal would do that and just a random
twitter person terrible it's like 808
okay and then he responds to that and
for the record those wild accusations
are utterly
untrue see he didn't tell insider that
interestingly
when they asked for a comment remember
he said there's more to the story that
does that's very different than utterly
untrue
and then that's when he of course
challenges her to describe his penis
which as you know is the ultimate uh
test
of dispelling
the well-known penis description
phase of every case like this describe
my penis could you do it and we've been
married we've been together for 15 years
go ahead you let other than saying
circumcised i mean it was circumcised
okay that's about half or more of the of
[Applause]
oh wait jordan describe my penis please
i dreamed i saw my maternal grandmother
sitting by the bank of a swimming pool
wait what i think his mind had the
appearance of a thick mat of hair oh
there he was very close with his grandma
at first
her genital region was exposed dimly
jordan
jordan was off topic a little bit you're
just awesome she was stroking herself
absent-mindedly
jordan gordon
this is not what i okay he missed the
point of the bit that guy has deranged
uh anyway
he he keeps responding to these people
is strange how their friend you can go
pila if you need to i just
love hear
this one reply so i don't want to go but
let me read it then it's strange how
their friend is the one who came forward
years after it supposedly happened while
claiming they can't stay silent it's a
story based on hearsay my friend said no
proof
exactly elon said moreover the friend in
question who gave the interview
wait what's b
what's that business insider
okay bi is far left activist
oh the friend is a far-left activist
actress in la with a major political act
grant it's like okay dude like shut up
that's just like stupid that's just
weird that means he knows who's the
friend and he looked her up and what
she whatever he knows he's just the way
he's framing it he's just trying to play
and then the
narrative the fact that he even replied
to this at all and said exactly
and it's like well you know that you
made them sign an nda so what do you
mean exactly it's like if the girl
wanted to tell the story herself she
can't
yeah what happened to free speech though
where are you going to mention that he's
fighting for free speech
yeah right
right nda he's doing it for all of us
nda
is
you can't speak when you sign an nda
that can't be right because elon musk is
a free speech absolutist no that's just
when it comes to enemies of the mosque
right but if we're in it we shouldn't
worry right he says absolutist though he
says i'm fighting for speech speech for
everyone does that include the girl
that's sent to nda not me not you he
goes free speech for everyone not you
afraid i was saying it's free speech for
everyone
not you you you
you signed nda's
um no it was so he said did you respond
to business insider he said no it was
clear their only goal was to hit peace
to interfere with the twitter
acquisition
no if any first of all business insider
the only thing they're after and being
honest is just getting clicks for the
website i don't think
they care about
and that's right he's saying the story
was written before they even talked to
me so like how much before was it before
the twitter that's normal by the way
you write the story but he's blaming it
on the twitter acquisition
when did they when did the story come up
i don't know i have no law i don't have
no idea how long they've been wrong it'd
be interesting to find out
but that's how it works i mean
you write the article and then you reach
out for a comment
but i'm just being honest business
insider is far from
like i said there's a reason the new
york times didn't break this story i
think that's a fair point
that's fine i i get that but
i just want to in my opinion it just
doesn't
mean that the story story's not real no
personal i'm saying of course not of
course not
uh but yeah this is interesting because
he says he didn't tell them anything but
business insider explicitly says he said
there's more of this story so
i don't know if he's going to sue them
that'll be interesting as well a lawsuit
could backfire on him though because
then he has to do discovery
and basically all the nda and all the
meetings and stuff basically becomes
public i think at that point through
discovery right
i don't think he's interested in that
but on the flip side
without even a lawsuit i mean
can't
this will do nothing to him can't he
just say
i release this person from all
uh
ndas you absolutely could play
absolutely absolutely
he could absolutely release her from the
nda
in fact he didn't do anything i mean i
don't see why not
he absolutely should um
yeah
if he's innocent
uh he should release her but i don't
think it's gonna matter he made this
really shrewd and intentional
decision to
join
the basically anti-cantal culture pseudo
free speech guys
i mean look trump was accused by like 13
different women yeah didn't matter you
know what i mean
these guys become untouchable once they
come into this crowd this right-wing
crowd right mega crowd it's like you
can't do
anything uh you know what's the worst
thing you could do if you're a mega
crowd is probably
say something nice about obama
or like i don't know uh
be gay being gay is bad you know that's
a tough one
that's a hard that's a better pill to
swallow
thank you dan
but anyway that's the story
um and elon is just gone you know i mean
it's kind of crazy he's just down the
meme hole now um
here is by the way
what in the [ __ ] is this you guys see
this sports illustrated cover
now this is a beautiful mamma mia a
wooga a wooga haman
i love me some grammy milkers
uh
graham graham peterson
shows off her soft
handmade paint brushes wait are the is
those her pubes
oh no
man oh god
those are the appearance of a thick mat
of hair those are definitely her pubes
that is
that that is just a demented mine my
maternal grandmother sitting by the bank
of a swimming pool
this is just disgusting man
i let her have her way
god
unbelievable
well
that man is is severely disturbed
um exposed dimly
there you have it
um yeah there it is
what else
uh since we're between stories i'll just
acknowledge this donation it just came
through from ishaan kumar a five dollar
donation an icu doctor uh been family
for years i caught covet on the line of
duty resting and watching the podcast
shout out to a.b from michigan by the
way
thanks you sean shout out to all the
doctors out there do you want me to give
uh ab like 12 percent of that donation
or just let me know do you want to split
that up at all let me know how you want
me to split that up yeah
thank you so much appreciate you shout
out to uh
the family
shout out to the island
um how long we've been going dan
uh two hours 37 minutes and 59 seconds
so let's see let's go back to um
there's some stuff we missed
from the beginning wally p sent us a
message this is interesting
why are we not already coordinating a
meeting with him what's going on well i
think because we haven't yet
acknowledged it on the show and i think
now that we're doing so this is our
chance he's going to see this
we can tell them how to get in touch
with us
um
because they didn't give any contact
details well go ahead and watch this
video and you tell me you know what to
do with this
we've been trying to get in contact with
him for years
yeah
and now he's acknowledging us and we
still don't know how to get in contact
with him here's the video he sent us
uh
[Music]
his cameos would slap so so hard man
yeah
okay but so you guys aren't in touch
with tony
not yet but tony if you see this which i
since you're aware of us now i'm sure
this is going to get back to you wait
didn't we post on our subreddit before
huh i thought tony posted a video of uh
he's the guy who's been hanging he's
doing well videos yeah he helped him set
up a youtube channel and stuff
because he's just been on tick tock up
to this point tony dan
h3h3productions.com yeah this is my
email please send me an email we'd love
to talk to you we spoke to someone else
that supposedly knew him but that was a
that was yeah you know what
they're in texas texas texas because i
would like to set up a mobility scooter
race
oh interesting because now that i
learned he's on a mobility scooter yeah
would you fly there for that
because i think he would have to go
there i don't think he would come
yeah i don't is that worth the trip out
there though i might be thinking about
it
it may be it i don't know
if you don't want to go it means that
we'll go yeah
gladly we've been chasing yeah
maybe
you and zach did you really just cut me
out of the safety i'm sorry i'm sorry
you know how i feel about wally people
dan is a big advocate for her but right
me and zach i think have sat through his
live streams for hours hey hold on hold
on hold on
love says he heads into in contact with
tony is that right love i'm not in
contact with him but i know he's a
member of uh
the
wally discord that i'm a member of
okay so
okay we'll love it yeah
dm all right maybe we can pick the ball
rolling maybe well texas he could he
probably is too big for an airplane he's
a big guy yeah but it's possible we
could get them to
drive or take a train or a bus or
something
we could charge her a nice car so it's
comfortable for him maybe we could get
him like one of those luxury mercedes we
can rent like a touring bus well yeah
right i'm just saying there's got to be
a way what if we do a whole wrap to the
touring bus with like wall-e
custom decals yeah diwali teep feed
scoring bus yeah
dude that's kind of epic actually we can
even get a disability one where he can
he can cruise in with his mobility
scooter and everything
a disability mobility
i'm just saying
we can work we can figure this out
all right well let's just let's speak to
him let's get creative
take that just maybe i'm getting ahead
of myself putting the mobility scooter
before the horse
as they say
the saying of old um
best friend dr eddie lucky
christina thank you
i heard a.d and casino i heard christina
is he talking about your mom's house
uh but did they talk about him too i
don't know i i've got his chance i got
his chat chanting
family and like age three before but
that's my only connection to him that's
the only time i've ever even got close
well we're getting close i think you got
acknowledged i mean this is not this is
we are getting closer and closer to the
elusive wall-e p
this is coming to fruition perhaps the
hardest guest
in the history of h leader pursue i mean
it's probably
been over two years of of talking about
wall-e at this wow yeah almost two years
yeah the hunt for wally p it could we
could make an interesting documentary
about this i think in the end
i mean what we've been able to puzzle
together about his life it seems like
he's he's had a wild one
lightly i was in contact i guess i won't
yeah i won't say but someone very close
to him and
i'm just going to leave it at that yeah
well what did they say
i'll tell like i said i'll tell you up
there yeah yeah oh you don't have
anything
okay interesting i thought you're gonna
okay
well
it's all coming together
20 gifted subs from frederico anderson
just now thank you so much for watching
that's so freaking
wait did he do it twice
yeah oh my god i missed the other one
that's so generous man and shout out to
the
bro thank you so much to frederico that
is just so nice man
the gifted sub is so nice it's so family
i just love it it's a good vibe
by the way we should plan when we're
going to want to do the uh tiptoes
uh movie uh members live stream
we want to come back in on the on a
saturday again and watch uh the the
movie about uh
the one with uh gary oldman as a little
person is it tiptoes yeah oh it is
tiptoes yeah where gary in the role of a
lifetime gary oldman pretends to be a
little person and walks on his knees the
whole time then you see the trailer for
that i think maybe dude if it's a meme
on the show yeah yeah you definitely
haven't seen it but yeah
years ago but it came up again
so okay they said in the trailer the
role of a life
so this weekend we have plans right yeah
but next weekend potentially um well
huh let me see
we'll figure it out it'll yeah we'll
have to well i just want to put on a
show for all of our new family members
but yeah yeah
but uh that'll be fun
um actually the member's life the
members live stream give us an
opportunity to do stuff we would never
do yeah right
i think a lot of members will be really
happy with behind
tomorrow because there's huge names in
it like
yeah
say what there's a lot of big names that
are going to be behind oh the bts is
dropping tomorrow is going to be yeah i
mean abe was in there with all of all
the big boys right yeah they had like a
big mixer and everyone was there
critical and um zach lewis is going to
be in the behind the scenes did you get
a comment from critical
uh no i didn't you just got a shot of
him yeah did you get a shot of you just
looked at him from across the u.s a
creeper a creep shot actually me and him
are talking in the background and lena's
recording my brother hitting this
punching bag it's it's sick stuff it's
there yeah wow you did capture his voice
that sounds like ribbon conversation so
there you go they're quite a pitch to
the bts
coming up this weekend for all of our
wonderful members another 20 gifted subs
from annelise
it's crazy thank you thank you so much
family family family forever
uh i just got a response from tony by
the way that was fast
on it yeah oh
oh he's on it okay all right oh and
here's the preview of uh the bus that
we're gonna put together
okay there yes yes yes yes
this could be a hazard on the road man
i think people will be crashing all
around that bus
some of the chat saying my cousin tim
needs to translate for him
every arab i've asked cannot place his
accent like and i'm the same way i will
ask what let's ask him let's have tony
ask what's his native wait we know where
he's we know where he's from he's from
uh it's he speaks kurdish
right yeah yeah
is he from northern iraq originally i
think i think so northern iraq has been
told so many lies throughout these past
two years yeah yeah right so is are
there any fans in the audience who uh
speak kurdish that could help i've asked
some of my kurdish friends and they but
do we have him speaking kurdish because
he's usually doing some kind of mix it's
it's usually a mix of several english
kurdish and arabic yeah i think
yeah yeah so if anyone out there speaks
kurdish and arabic
and uh
walian
because we're definitely going to need a
translator if we want to have a series
there's multiple dialects of kurdish too
makes it even worse play that again zach
and if you know what he's saying here
well he
says which is spanish okay
he's lived in texas for a long time so
i'm sure he's picked up spanish i think
he could get by with arabic and english
we need a whole panel of
translators on standby somebody said i
can speak chinese if that helps yeah i
think it would
we'll take what we could get join the
panel
like lena could piece together
most of the time what he says but it
just it takes a while okay interesting
so here we have a we have a
an in-house
translator thank you so much to elon's
crotch
who just donated 20 gifted subs
thank you so much elon's crotch rod
ladies
to the family you know you get that
crotch rot i sure do i sure do
that crotch rot
so anyway let's let's keep going let's
let's just clear the dock since we're
here you know what i mean
let's clear this bee out uh this is
erupt abrupt chaos let's see what we got
here
oh i've seen this i have seen this and
i'm curious like
you know i thought to myself what would
i do if this happened to me
oh [ __ ] oh
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] i don't know what to do
guys i don't know forget about the
camera
[ __ ] i love she's still putting oh she's
live streaming yeah
i love that she's staying focused on the
goal what does she do
[Music]
don't you like just like turn it off
with a towel i don't know because it's a
grease fire can we learn with your
brother baking soda yeah baking soda
baking soda
nothing is on fire bad oh my god
so
so i was wondering what would i do if i
was i think i
i was thinking what i would probably
have done is just put it in the oven
because you know it's not going to burn
anything
i would probably just throw it in the
oven
isn't the right thing to do with a
grease fire like that to either smother
it or or cover it in some way
i think if i yeah yes but or put baking
soda on it we learned right that'll
immediately put it out but i'm just
thinking i'm there panicking i need to
make a snap judgment i'm throwing it in
the oven and closing it there's probably
worse things to do than that yeah just
get it out get it in the oven you know i
think the worst thing is to try to talk
to your chat dump it in the sink which
is what she did obviously the biggest
sin when you have a grease fire is to
throw water on it because that just
makes it explode everywhere
she's so concerned with like still
entertaining the show yeah god bless her
she's a 200 maybe maybe
take the cutting board and put it on top
of the pan could have been a good play
right
to smother the flame
um
you want to do the philly do stuff we
can do that
let's see
philly been philly d
billy about to take these these nuts in
his mouth
because he's been talking mad [ __ ] on me
and i'm not trying to box anyone but
philly's about to catch these hands dude
by the way you guys took a poll and
thank you to all of our great football
troopers 70 said philly d would win in a
fight
our own audience yes our own
our own army
be your own
my own people say i'll get my ass beat
by philly deep you're really living
on the verge of organ failure
his kidney barely works man
so let's see what he had to say well i
was talking to ian he wants me to fight
phillyd
that's where he came from
yeah he's yeah yeah dude he [ __ ]
fired the first shots i was like all
right
i was like all right you know what i'm
gonna do i'm gonna train and i'm just
gonna get really good at kidney shots
i'm just going to practice one motion
straight for the kidney
and i'll you know i'll kill you
i'll just kill you in the ring bro you
better have that organ donor lined up
just saying bro i just thought of that
just saying that a little too far
yeah then threatened to kill him it's
that's not cool but the thought of you
two in a boxing ring and he's just
hitting you in the face and you keep
going for the same shot repeatedly
here's a kidney strike here here's a
kidney strike
so oh god these guys are goons
this is me and philly d fighting i
thought this would be cooler
show me the kidney strike yeah so here
it is okay let's cut to the chase here
please just so you guys could see my one
move if me and philly ever did box
so here's my one move
i don't even know where the kidney is
currently i don't know where that is in
the body
but he's about to show me there it is oh
yeah dude that's nuts i just keep going
for his side
can you imagine i'm actually just trying
to [ __ ] try
and we're cracking up just imagine you
just continuously going
they're not legal in boxing are they why
not no they are and they they take you
out what yeah it's a body shot yeah and
like george foreman was known for his
kin it's there's no pain like it i've
gotten one of them and it's you just
collapsed oh really yeah i could rupture
his though because his is
his uh yeah i mean he has a condition
apparently and
you know
so that's me you see that that's the
whole this is the whole boxing match
that's funny right
it's okay it's pretty funny
that the box would be like he's going
for his kidney philly d is known he has
a kidney condition ethan is trying to
kill him right now what i think would be
funny is well after you
if you get on stage i just i envision
you doing like all your dance moves oh
yeah
and i think that's gonna be funny
oh i'm seeing oh i'm seeing that kidney
shots are not legal oh for real oh shots
are legal cause stallone said that in a
spy kid's part three um
kidney punches are not legal in boxing
really i just thought it was a normal
body shot i mean
i can make it look like an accident
right yeah that's what i'm saying people
do it all the time so that must be what
it is they just
maybe they lose points or something
sweep the kidney
i don't care about points if he dies i
win
right
technically yes there you go we love
philly d though over here
we're all philly fans we're not trying
to kill him who are you
who authorized that statement
all right let's watch
he has like an organ thing he's like you
guys like his got all kinds of things
no but my i don't have organ failure
i [ __ ] myself
defranco who is too stunned to speak
okay so in ethan's defense it is true
that i only have one spleen but that's
because everyone only has one spleen
actually that's not true about ten
percent of people have two spleens it's
called an accessory spleen i just
learned that this morning we'll get to
that after i say sup you beautiful
bastards welcome back to the philippines
there's a compilation the doc of him
talking about if you just want to watch
that
no i just wanna
oh so if that's that's all you said
about me
there's more all right yeah yeah yeah
let's see all the trash talk
uh
philly d wants the smoke here's the
highlight
this is all from that episode yeah
well i was talking to ian he wants me to
fight philly d
no really okay you watch this speak
urban fighting which is
yesterday if you watched h3tv the news
broke he said philly is seriously
considering fighting which was
absolutely massive news to a number of
people including me because that's not a
thing that's absolutely
because he actually interviewed ian is
that in this
uh yeah it's it's in this compilation
right okay i'll just let it play then
finding out who the [ __ ] is lying about
me as well as to provide equal
representation for yesterday's dr mike
interview we have idubbbz coming in for
a quick chat so yeah the first thing i
really like
did you tell ethan klein that i was
interested in boxing as a way to trick
him into fighting me well i i thought i
don't know where i heard it i thought i
thought you were interested what what
are you talking about i i don't know
maybe it got lost in communication but i
thought you were down to fight at least
ethan i was like then you would be a
good fight yeah i don't think it would
be a fair fight even though yesterday he
said he could kill me
was that was that confusion or is that
is that a tactic so philly really thinks
he could beat my ass huh
i mean look
he's a bigger guy
he's a little taller
he's bulkier i know that most people
think i get my ass beat and i understand
that i'm not offended by it you are not
in shape but if you guys saw me at my
physical prime
um
every blood test i've said says that i'm
an elite athlete whatever that
kardashian quote is
oh if you
exercised you could philly d you know
you keep ignoring uh the suggestion that
you listen or not
wait that i need to exercise well i'm
not fighting him not in my current
position in my current condition right
not fighting anybody but you'd fight him
five years ago when you were in your
prime
if we trained for a year i'm saying
hypothetically okay
i'll i'll say two things one you brag
about being unhealthy all the time so i
can see why a lot of people
philly
there's a reason philly shoots from the
chest up that's all i'll say
go ahead
he's skinny though yeah like we showed
your like lime green pesto on on stream
people doubting you but the other thing
is and dan brought this up the other day
um when we're talking about this is that
you are you do have like some weird
athletic abilities i think i do you
really do like the baseball was one of
the examples no i i think like i am
i am i am athletic i am
it's crazy right i mean i'm an old guy
i'm out of shape but like i have i think
i have naturally good balance and
athletic abilities when i'm you know
training and stuff i just think it would
take a lot of training to be able to but
yeah i think you're overestimating how
much shape philly d is
i think he's in shape yeah he did lose a
lot of weight recently
i think you are underestimating
can it be both
yeah thank you
either way i'm not fighting him but i'm
just saying i like to i like to
fantasize that
in a world where we actually fight
i think it would be it would be a close
spark for the show it would be a good
show
the thing is i would have to train so
hard you would yeah i mean you saw it
and i've got kids
you're gonna um i mean it's gonna be
long-ass days without you know what i
mean i'll have to wake up early and go
to bed early it's just gonna be well
that's fine but i'm just saying like
it's gonna be long [ __ ] days
we got two young kids i will
support your
philly's dad training time if that's
what these kids are older they're like
away for
if you're away for for training
well well if i just practice the kidneys
like once a week if you want to come
with me one of the times you're still
doing it once a week once a week yeah
yeah
just once right that's enough
once a week well i just go once just
once yeah i just want that's where the
kidney is and wally will show you you'll
just you just go in the ring with one
glove
if if we fought now philly would would
you know
he would probably win but
that's true of anyone on to be honest
with you guys
i don't think i could beat up a single
living person
but if you agree to it
then you've made the commitment that's
serves as the motivation
to you know actually train and get in
better shape but i don't even know
philly according to philly he's not even
fighting anyone
well it seemed like
let's hear this let's hear this that you
use to actively get some of the people
on the last card to fight oh no not at
all everyone was super down to do it
without like even knowing who their
opponent was and two ethan klein i never
said i wanted to fight you if i did you
would get hurt and that would go against
my monetary interest because then i
wouldn't be able to put your beautiful
pace in my mind
the question i want to kick out to you
beautiful bastards is even though i
would not fight who would you like to
see me [ __ ]
[ __ ] me
who else you gonna
fight you know
god the memes would be so good though i
could get like i could come out with
like the donor list
or like a fake kidney and [ __ ] the [ __ ]
talk would go i'll come out to the box
room with like a ice chest with like a
kidney inside
oh my god the [ __ ] talking could go so
good
[Laughter]
my boxing name could be ethan kidney
rupture klein
it'd be so
fire
but i don't think he's got the balls
frankly to fight me
even and then this of course shout out
to the super trooper family
a pul someone put this poll up
zero points by the way uh she didn't
said he might it wasn't the other day
how did you guys find this at zero
points you guys found the pull of me
saying i'm gonna get my ass beat
uh with zero points
oh cause we made it that's that's right
i voted for you
sure you did of 200 votes uh 120
pretty astounding uh
ratio think philly the news king
beats me so
i don't blame you guys though
it's not looking good for me
definitely
so there you have it philly d
um actually i'm obviously just goofing
around we had funny exchange on twitter
and even his wife made a really funny
comment when i said i tweeted out
something like i would absolutely
rupture phillyd's
kidney if we boxed
and his wife was said something really
funny like that this could actually work
out good because he's going to need a
replacement kidney anyway maybe it gets
to the top of the donor list speed it
along yeah
very funny i i had a good chocolate of
that and then uh he said something about
ryan kevin oh yeah he says not after
rank have enough funds in my training
camp
i was like okay well ryan kavanaugh's
broke he lost almost a billion dollars
last year nice try he's not paying for
anyone's training camp
that was my ultimate diss thank you
where's the one from his wifey
it was in that thread
oh careful there's there's bat oh here
it is liz defranco he's gonna need a
transplant at some point anyway
so you may actually help him move up on
the waiting list there you have it doing
a service
there you have it
my current beef
with philip defranco
awesome
what about bobby lee fight bobby lip
that's interesting
uh he likes video games as well
well he's also isn't he 50 50. yeah he's
old
yeah it's probably not the best idea
perfect
actually interestingly me and philly are
like one year apart
we're pretty close in size i'm 5 11 he's
six foot
obviously i think i probably got him
i don't know
he
but i'm saying like the stats are pretty
close
interestingly
in terms of age
right and height yeah
but also you and wally are close in age
and height
my coach
right so it doesn't matter
right
maybe i should fight your club
good luck
um
i think we
oh yeah dude this thumbnail was so
[ __ ] awesome look at this the love
made this we're just click betting the
drama uh we said my issue with philip
defranco's reporting and we were just
joking about how he doesn't i was just
complaining that i'm not in enough
thumbnails and that hassan's been in
more mm-hmm
and then we go weird and gross
my issue with philip defranco's
reporting did that one get views by the
way love
uh
i really did find like 65k views oh he
he commented that's
i'm very proud of that wait how many
views do you get
65k for a two-minute clip not bad
i'll take it
pretty funny though
so i think we pretty much
closed this
episode out let me see yeah it's almost
four o'clock uh too and i know you guys
have to head out yeah i think we talked
about every except scooby-doo movie
which apparently is super violent let me
see this image i'm not going to put on
the screen
it's a cartoon
for adults
is that right that's good it is
a adult theme here look at this this is
a trailer
so i seeing like her head is cut wide
open
very graphic and then also the hot uh
daphne is like butt ass naked
so weird well she has soap over her
private so you can't like see
but she's
now people are getting mad because the
main character velma they uh made her
southeast asian instead of white which
is dumb who cares like doesn't matter um
i just thought it was indeed
yeah it's mindy kaling is behind it oh
well that's fair i mean
representing herself yeah and it's
obviously
who cares i mean it's a cartoon
character
um
but i just we were all discussing it and
we were like
is it it's weird that like all these
weird insults are freaking out about the
race swap but everybody like it's a
scooby-doo show with nudity and like
graphic gore it's just like they really
what it
is
yeah [ __ ] about the
vel or whatever her name is velma
that's so dumb like it makes me want to
spit in fact
velma looks like the original character
it's not even like it's a different
character it's just her skin's a little
darker yeah
that's kind of [ __ ] stupid like y'all
really are looking pathetic
uh mindy is giving a first look at her
hbo max i'm sorry south asian not
southeast asian i misspoke people are
correct um velma tells the original
story
of velma dinkley of the scooby-doo gang
spin-off show is part of hbo's max to
drive to beef up
adult animation programming
so there you go everyone who always
wanted to beat off to scooby-doo
i mean there's a lot of fantasies going
around scooby-doo the women of
scooby-doo so velma in particular even
though like daphne is the more
traditionally uh beautiful depicted
character velma is the sex icon right
because you know she's a freak
velma oh let's see
cast of scooby
doo original let's see let's line them
up
uh
yeah yeah exactly
let's take a look here so
i let her have her way
[Music]
there's ones where she looks hotter than
this where they don't play up like the
they kind of play i feel like they play
it up more in certain iterations of
scooby-doo
yeah i think over the years they've uh
leaned into it a little bit wait hold on
let me before i don't want to google
anything insane let me do velma
she was stroking herself
absent-mindedly velma sexy
scooby-doo
here i want to show you guys some
oh my god yeah it's just all her genital
region was exposed dimly
velma scooby-doo here let's take the sex
yo
it had the appearance of a thick mat of
hair
yeah i mean the actress is pretty who
played her yeah there was a meme about
her being hot and she had like a low-cut
top with cleavage out that's possessed
velma
oh she got possessed and got sexy yeah
it's possessed oh [ __ ] nutty they're
fine but here obviously like a beautiful
uh
purse a beautiful girl is playing her
i mean yeah here she looks a little like
she got that
that underboob shadow going on
be careful scrolling through google
images
i'm telling you right now it's just
scooby-doo it just says scooby-doo i'm
just saying there's a lot i did sexy
first and that was not good
i just did hot and that wasn't good i
let her have her way
let me see
yeah i can see she got like that you
know nerdy she got freckles people are
into that
[Music]
let's see
yeah is anybody going to be watching
this show
oh see now here she got now this is what
i'm talking about
you know she has nice legs
her genital region was exposed dimly
all right i should stop scrolling now
well that's the show guys
i hope you had fun today
covered a lot of ground didn't i right
it's been a whole journey very nice
um next monday
what's happening return of olivia today
i have bad news for her i just saw my
phone pete davidson leaves snl
oh he's too big for that show
ripped
damn tragic
that's crazy bro
that's not student
anyway olivia's back next week right
yeah
uh thank you to all everyone who gifted
thank you everyone just too uh
donated mega awesomener damn stop giving
us all your money we live in a beautiful
timeline we got this velma show super
saiyan shaggy
and now ugly sonic is back what a time
to be alive did they bring ugly i saw
something about that so it's a gag in i
guess there's a is it the
the rescue rangers like movie that's
coming out uh i forget the name of it
chippendale
yeah exactly yep
and
i guess they they go to like a comic-con
convention at some point and the ugly
sonic is there like like how like a bee
washed up celebrity like is always
signing things
uh
which that's a good guy uh sean said uh
sean mckean says can i get a shout out
to gaylord michigan is that a real is
that the real name of a town yeah uh we
just experienced a tornado destroyed our
entire mainstream damn
thoughts go out to
gaylord
[Music]
michigan what's funny
yeah
love that
yes gaylord michigan is a real place uh
gaylord used to be a fairly common
surname yeah yeah
when i was a kid i thought that was the
funniest [ __ ] thing man
i there was a kid in my middle school
whose middle name is how is that a name
gaylord like uh meet the parent well
back back back in the day gay meant you
know mary right
right i think they i don't think they
use gay as a
as a word i believe that's a 20th
century yeah
because all of a sudden you got this
surname you're like hey he's a happy guy
then you you know turn the century
gaylord
because he's the lord of all gays
just i mean to really take that in yeah
like i was saying there i i there was a
kid
in my middle school whose middle name
was gaylord and people found out brutal
and this was in this was in like 1998
1999 in middle school
when things were
not nearly as woke as they are today and
uh as you can imagine that poor kid uh
got danced a lot that's even his middle
name it wasn't even like one of the
major names uh gaylord is a name from
norman french origin it means literally
joyful or high spirited
sure yeah
gaylord ladies and gentlemen
it's kind of a dope name i think like if
it didn't have the
the modern day
connotation
somebody just donated five british
pounds and said i have a great name his
name is jaylord
j lord
slow clap
um
there's a live animation scooby-doo show
on youtube that's being funded on
kickstarter what
uh that's like unofficial that's gonna
get shut down i don't know that's what
he said he just said episode one is out
now
anyway thank you guys wow so many
generous people in the audience with the
with the gifted subs so nice uh thank
you guys so much
well i hope everyone has a a great
weekend
we will be back on monday as usual
um with olivia we got some fun goofs
planned
someone said check brittany broski's
socials what happened
britney
bruce
let's see
let's see
let me guess nothing's there
why did her account not come up
she has like 20 stories so somebody uh
mr poop gave me five bucks she said
please split this between shredder and
alfredo i will do that
thank you
thank you
all right
um
i am winding down do you see anything
down on a brief glance
uh her most recent tweet is just a goofy
gif there it is what's going on
guys have a great weekend we'll see you
on monday
elo congratulations on that first pitch
that was that was something yeah that's
very impressive
very impressive
absolutely
all right guys see you monday have a
great weekend
i let her have her way you'll see the
best podcast in the world take it from
me jc over chair hp baby we podcast now
you're watching h to the three three
three three you're watching h to the
three three three three you're watching
h to the three three three three three
you're watching h to the three three
three